what's up folks quick disclaimer on this
episode before we get started we may or
may not have had a slight power outage
mid episode shutting off the power board
and two of the camera angles rendering
all those files useless so that simply
means that for the first hour and a half
of this three and a half hour episode
the audio might not be quite the quality
that you're used to here on dope as
usual my camera angle is going to be
non-existent for some of this podcast we
won't be doing the multi-cam back and
forth switching angles for the first
hour and a half of this episode but
that's okay
this [ __ ] is so riveting we left it in
anyway because it's must-see not
acceptable i don't take these type of
mistakes lightly okay i got big 12 and a
half size 13 flat feet i'm wearing air
maxes i step on the power switch
apparently it happens mistakes are
unacceptable here in our world ready for
this
oh
god
jesus christ you guys forgive me thumbs
up in the chat if you guys forgive me
okay
i need to do another one get ready for
this episode guys mom episode part two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect yo what's up guys uh welcome
back to the doubles usual podcast my
name is thomas dopeziola whatever you
want to call me i am here with marty
o'neil what's up folks hello what's up
hello
special special edition guys today is a
guest you always ask for uh this is
susie from curb your enthusiasm all
right this is jeffrey
or my mom and her earring just fell off
did it mid podcast i love it
she had soap she was talking all this
about pirates
all the pirate jokes and then now
they're hearing that
i'm a pirate all right this is not susie
from curb it just i really love the fact
that you kind of look like her and she's
super mean
see in the show she's true i don't know
who that is i know and i love always
calling out susie over here
yeah you're if everybody out there that
watches curb you gotta know right like
crazy you look a lot like
that facebook
pop up no i didn't certain one of her in
a top hat that i have in my phone that
was she called
all right you ready no now what's up
guys
let's start this off this is the second
time my mom was here last year um
completely shit-faced that episode don't
remember anything you talked about you
were yes you were hammered so i had to
skim through it again to make sure i
didn't repeat myself oh i forgot you
were trying that's what i said i don't
know what we talked about it's the only
episode right blacked out
almost the whole thing
um
yeah are you ready i'm [ __ ] ready are
you ready
yes mother's day edition oh yeah
tomorrow's mother's day for everyone out
there for time
tomorrow's mother's day and um yesterday
did the first pop-up for the dopest ate
too many edibles so that's why maybe
you're like dennis as well as i i'm just
high still so i'm trying to bust through
it we're here you ready
let's get started i'm gonna start this
off super light super easy i know you
don't believe me i don't believe what's
your favorite three movies of all time
ah i wouldn't want to do that to me not
to born killers first no
in any order okay um
oh god
what genre is though can we do genres
favorite three comedies of all time
favorite three comedies of all time i
was just seeing you pick my housekeeper
for 42 minutes
i was gonna say like stuck on an island
you have like three oh three comedy
comedies and then we'll go to others
okay so comedies would have to be
probably calendar nights okay nice
um
it's cool
this is too hard i already know it's so
hard
to remind you of the lesson out there of
jim carrey i'm saying she's not a big
jim carrey fan i'm not she was on
christmas with gymnastics
not
[Music]
um
oh my god there's too many
that movies in general so talladega
nights natural killers
killers um but you're gonna get the
racial version not the
i thought that you're probably good
fellas oh yeah yeah okay thomas always
gives you credit for why he knows
[ __ ] everything about it but that's
why it's so hard because like three i
cannot i can't do it but also
it was a liar liar situation and
something you were sitting down like
but you did a couple um the one where
brad pitt and his little brother are
cross cut cross country runners oh god
and what is that rob says
rob something in rob's store and goes to
jail for a couple years you told me look
he's 18 or he's 16 he got out he's 19.
don't do stupid [ __ ] and i remember
literally he lost three years of his
life for robbing the store like i'm not
doing [ __ ] i am good kid and that did
get me yeah good fellas well we hear
about this all the time when i'm so
sketchy around people
fast times which are high oh there you
go
i could not believe i just skipped over
that one completely i know that's true
huh why would you say that right first i
don't know
whoa
no no good do you have a fun time okay
so sean penn sean pan and phoebe cates
that's the the most iconic scene of all
time when she's coming out of the water
and she opens her bikini
so
during that time every all the girls
wanted to be for uk i wanted to be cold
yeah
he was just he was the epitome of being
wearing bands being a stoner and being
awesome yeah he's cool this is uh sean
penn playing a server podcast
okay yeah it's green
no not that good
no i think sean penn is the inmate on
death row you know
into y y a which is the uh
prison for kids
it's really nice
that bad boys [ __ ] on wilson i still
have it
i still have one but it's a different
kind of movie yeah
it's not economy if you want comedy bad
boys actually one of the guards from
shawshank redemption
is the one that you have the shitty one
yeah yeah yeah we won't get too crazy
one was a little just like bust his
whole face with those doesn't talk about
too much because youtube's a dick oh but
yeah uh brutal it was brutal right
brutal
when he's leaving and he's getting
arrested at the end that guy yeah he's
in that movie about like at 16. he's
yeah he's plays a prisoner yeah great
movie bad boys watch it yeah go watch
bad boys the brother that if a ritchie
balance is in it too right
that's what i was thinking
he's awesome he's what my dad and my
parents thought we were okay
in the 90s mexican slick hair yeah you
thought you were cool or anybody from
blood and blood out if you were injured
i made that movie so i love it i cannot
i hate that's such a good one i don't
understand how you don't like it i
cannot stand that movie so showing life
italian no no because where i used to
work they played it every day
it didn't matter who was in their
children old lady oh that's right i did
not give a [ __ ]
underwear just left one up play in the
morning
all day long
just was it the plane no in madera when
i worked down at oh it's at the shop
yeah yeah i do remember that that's
pretty uh
pretty motivating you know at the end of
this all lives are terrible except for
the one that started it all now he's a
cop
blooded blood out you gotta watch that
benjamin breath that's your breath yeah
badass
yeah great movie damn okay so we started
off light
blooded blood out it's very light yeah
yeah but i do prefer cali mafia movies
over
it's with christopher walken it's uh
colin farrell and
sam rockwell woody harrelson plays a
gangster
it's
the best [ __ ] ever
it's a good good movie well you know i
love christopher walken wait so what's
the one with christopher walken where he
plays and babas he gets that's suicide
suicide yes yeah never mind good movie
that's a good ass movie christopher was
a great actor
so good also if you guys have some time
i just asked somebody yesterday for the
first time in life someone said yeah
i've seen it raising arizona go watch
that nicholas cage
and john goodman and john goodman buff
john goodman where he's still like
flintstones got john goodman
like pretty big
go watch that and then go watch true
romance
i love that character he plays gary
oldman and he just bought a whiteboard
yeah and he's so good plays a white
guy rastafarian black yeah jamaican
hmm yeah
all right we got a good start that was a
light start remember when you used to do
trip and i was kidding i wish you beat
the [ __ ] out of me all right let's move
on to my next topic remember we used to
beat the [ __ ] i'm scared top three
artists or bands ever led zeppelin
john's chocolate
iggy pop david bowie nah that's three
there's more than three well amy and
david bowie are like
hip-hop's great we can't say top three i
think you like them a lot for me yeah i
know but what bowie then bowie prince
great song i mean
of iggy pop yeah yes
all right well yeah all right
everybody yeah you really do like i do
adventures pete and pete he plays so
that's right that's like he's a clean
cut guy yeah that's iggy pop i'm talking
about yeah okay remember the little girl
the friend the dad the crazy dad okay
that's iggy pop
oh my god he was also in star trek
he plays he plays some character in star
trek
he was a crybaby he was in city of
angels the crow
that's maybe part two
i've never seen part two do you think
you and the directors are the only ones
i still watched it because icky pop was
in it [ __ ] out of here bro
okay well that's probably that's
probably about a bad what about that
actual zombie movie he just did it was
really good
um oh i didn't see it it's good i didn't
see it but i saw a preview for it um
so those are yours all right let's have
a giant chocolate icky pop david bowie
yeah
damn
that resembles james brown that's my dad
oh yeah okay yeah
we talked about it recently uh more
about the james brown
yeah
um okay that was cool i still remember
when i took him to see james brown right
before he died
you know before james
[Music]
uh well of course nwa easy
wu tang
odb
cypress hill
that's pretty much everything that
everyone watching i had an amazing
moment yesterday did you really
because that's how thomas i ride in
basically school i take my kids to
school every day and my daughter's like
almost 14 now so i'm like every day i
put her on something new
and
the other day she she put on uh blue
tang she did she really on the playlist
she had cash cash oh so she's playing
that i'm like wow this is trippy i'm
riding around i used to listen to this
[ __ ] on my way to school then my son
gets in the car
and he goes this is the fortnite skin
this is the evo
somebody emoted
is that hip-hop or is that reggae uh i
would say is in between they are they
ride the line very well yeah because
when they do hip-hop their hip-hop is
hard yeah and when they do everything
else it's great
you know my memory is insane brother do
you remember what you told me you wanted
me to play at your funeral i was like
three
oh
who's face odyssey was the space on you
yeah
that's probably still holy
oh that's why you were made to chunk for
a while what does that mean
and then i'm like oh the space captain
this guy that's all i remember like he's
a guy with all the [ __ ] crazy hair on
the walls of my house that's why i
remember as a kid
um okay that's that's cool
that was a good lineup uh-huh yeah solid
liner you know your shirt yeah of course
we do that oh pink floyd i think yeah
well i mean i really do that one though
what's your favorite thing for an album
between dark side of the moon and the
wall you have to go for those two the
wall if you're on mushrooms and pink
like just or the dark side of the moon
if you're just listening
to this a lot i like it because it just
takes you in the whole story yeah
because we're saying santa cruz
a perfect
amount of time my first mushroom trip i
watched dark side of the home music
videos oh did you yeah
it was [ __ ] amazing yeah
yeah cool toys on some other [ __ ] i
think one of them was nailing or
something
for your brain to process all of that
roger waters is an alien
i don't know i said i think
what happened to these people like that
roger waters they broke up
there was a dude that went crazy right
yes they made shine on a crazy diamond
about one i don't i don't
yeah they they he had to step away from
the band
yeah
music history something they're not very
strong yeah i'm not really well-versed
in the whole story but i'm sure the fans
are shouting some of their comments
right there's no one probably
she doesn't know what she's saying yeah
you're older than me i know this i also
have a 401k at my job
shut up
there's gonna be that guy
oh yeah um so yeah people
all right those are good light ups
you started off light and eat your head
let's see
i'm gonna pull up on that it's still
like what very early
yeah i mean
i could just like read this yeah yeah
it's over it's about to be fun yeah i'm
just gonna
i'll do a contact you ready no
my next date
do you remember getting into your car
accident when you [ __ ] your face up
what happened and then i'll proceed that
it's actually it's a stupid story so i
was on lunch because i worked at a wine
place no mclean mcclain oh well it's a
place
off of that child
and i went to lunch real quick and i was
coming back and i was like really
driving like an [ __ ] but oh driving
like an ass but then marvin gaye came on
so i slowed down to listen to the song
and while i was like slowing down
i think i was like going before you
maybe a rod robber
ran out of my car didn't even see it
and took out the whole front of my car
and when you hit it you went into the
ditch
i went off to the side but it was a
canal
yeah i just know i just kind of like i
held on
but then the bags came out and all that
off that's what [ __ ] you up [ __ ] i'm
dead it's all white like when the thing
comes out it covers your face and then
it's all like
i thought i was [ __ ] dead i was like
cool
[Music]
i thought it was me in my head thinking
of the whiteness take over
no so then i felt the burning and then i
was like oh [ __ ] burning so i'm still
alive yeah
by that time people have stopped and
like are you okay this is at night
though no there was dusk something
[Music]
okay so
moving on
i think we talked about i don't know we
talked about it on our episode but i've
talked about it before
then like a day or two later we went up
to mariposa
to i don't know what we called him
my old stepdad your old husband we'll
just say that that guy we just what are
we gonna
so we go up to peter's sister's house in
mariposa or did we tell a story we did
tell the story last time where you
almost got eaten by a lion oh yeah a
cougar did we talk about all this
oh that was hilarious so my stepdad i
told you he was essentially edward
norton from
american history yeah it's like
even now i don't want to find him don't
want to fight him i outweigh him
i don't want to fight that guy he's
probably like 160. no
he
every time i see conor mcgregor i think
it was just like his [ __ ] the
way he just like
tatted crazy [ __ ] white guy rabbit
bite your face off
that's what he reminds me of especially
when he's going nuts like fighting i'm
like damn
yeah
that guy we went up to mariposa i'll
tell the story first went to
and we stay tonight i love sports i'm
really good at sports i joined a new
soccer team
for the new season
and we said hey mom we're going to
mariposa i have a game in the morning
remember we didn't go did we
i'm sorry
i'm sorry this is probably why i have a
fear of being late everywhere
because of this [ __ ]
no dude like uh i wake up obviously on
time like all right let's go and you go
what the [ __ ] did you just say but it
was back when i'm still scared of you so
why
okay i'm sorry so we didn't go to the
soccer game what happened
yeah she did what she did no what i
can't dispute it because you probably
sit down hey then you go to thomas
peter looks the way he does look at my
face oh that's right
that's
true he could just take me
that's true too you know and i go in my
head
because he can just take me
and i can play my game that i'm the
captain i never showed my face again on
the team
i was so embarrassed i didn't want to
come back he called her
i don't remember that i remember
i don't remember the coach the coach it
wasn't the first the first year you
played you and that kid and everything
oh yeah you guys were insane they took i
can't i cried and they took me out
i had 11 goals of one year and then the
second year you played that member of
that coach was terrible dude i cried
being a goalie one year and i remember
about you or michael robbie in front of
me like why is he crying i was so upset
crying just there was no defense i'm the
defense i'm the goalie they scored like
six goals in a row on me and i was
losing my [ __ ] mind out there like
none of you guys are going to help me i
look like i can't play [ __ ] sports
now
anyway we didn't go she said look at his
face
look or look at my face look at him yeah
he beat me up yeah that's true just drop
me up
no and that's when i never showed up
again i started well they were i didn't
have a car either though you got to
mariposa no no not the van
no no no no no
no that wasn't you
listen
that was when i still had the mazda
because that's why i hit the car the dog
in and they had to tell me oh you're
right you're the other one
lincoln the one that drives like how we
got tamira posted tonight before
yeah
you think you're gonna as an adult go to
mayor pose and go you know what i don't
have a car we're never coming back never
going home again see we're gonna see the
mountain you see the logic here i tried
mom you can't look you can't go you know
what it was we didn't have a car we
walked to mariposa
[Music]
so yeah that that's that's what happened
damn i know you don't know
i remember
that's what happened and i felt i can't
come back i am sorry
the leading scorer and
did you have a lot of public uh
incidents with peter where like people
were running up on them over his hats
no no
weird no never us a few times we used to
do stupid [ __ ] in like stores and stuff
and scared the [ __ ] out of people that
was great what do you mean okay i'm just
thinking you're walking around a
predominantly mexican town for gang
magnet mexican dude right yeah but those
game ring races are scared of him oh
okay they know when they go to prison
and they see him it's gonna be bad
gotcha like you gotta remember like
prisoners don't forget
like you have don't worry folk i'll see
you in jail like
when you find out how
unbelievably violent this man is usually
you don't go
because you know what i'm talking about
well i wasn't
he if i knew about something you knew
about some of this stuff and he told you
wait what he told me he was you wouldn't
tell me well he told me enough and he
told you obviously the same things that
he would tell a child
you know certainly you don't go to
prison why should we look down no no i
know something but i mean this right
here you can tell you know more than
you're trying to say
i know your face very well
but i feel like sometimes [ __ ] jesus
object
that was me but matching me
all right i guess there's a [ __ ] here
man one two three four five exactly
yeah so what but in your defense there
are women that date like gangster dudes
though i i didn't live in a cage you
didn't look like a gangster upstairs
i didn't put a gangster he did not look
like a gangster shredded
yeah
here too no test from here no
exactly but like willie he was loved
like like groundskeeper william
he was [ __ ] ripped bro like scary but
he could blend in no he plays in great
yeah
i always pictured him as like some no
when he takes his shirt off yeah you're
like oh yeah yeah i don't know gotcha
nope and when he had long hair like no i
don't want to be buying him was he gonna
[ __ ] the people in public though no
no he's respectful
you would never know
you never know how scary the guy next to
you is
that's where anybody does this that's
great but you never know yeah but
especially he hit it pretty good he did
it well because he always said no
tattoos pass here because he wants to
get a job he wants to live in a society
but he's held a felony
i remember everything he was trying to
get that job into college
and he passed as a professor of
engineering
they're like oh we ran your background
chicken you have to get out
they're not even allowed here
no they would let him online i know i'm
kidding oh he was leave earth yeah it
was pretty bad
he got lucky before the three strikes
you're out that's what happened and then
he got three strikes you're out now so
oh did he i think so yeah i would get
some [ __ ] i'm like wait that's another
strike he's done that's it
um i don't you know if he had like
many felonies and only two strikes so he
got left before
yeah you got lucky so you guys broke up
and he just went off and did his own
thing he didn't keep like coming back in
the equation yeah
yeah what do you mean he went back well
she didn't let him back no hell no but
he didn't leave anybody alone that's
what he's asking are you bothering did
he bother you he bothered you well he
bothered me until that's what i said
and then after that he knew better than
messi no he did not vlog he did not stop
here
and he didn't know what to do he'd kill
our whole
he decided that it wasn't worth his time
anymore and then you moved on
say it right no he could have killed
anybody
okay listen yeah that's true
but but that's anybody could kill
anybody
he's a terminator
well out of everybody you've ever met
who do you least want to piss off if you
like to the death of that there
am i wrong
anybody you've ever met or encountered
he might be the most scariest violent
[ __ ] if you've ever met
yeah but i'm an idiot i'm not scared of
him i know that i'm saying in general if
you were a random dude down the street
that's true though he's a scary
[ __ ] out of jail i'm saying he
decided to leave you alone because he
decided because he bugged you until
right okay hold on but
no i don't know if i should say
no say hey no he wasn't he wasn't
allowed to contact me whatsoever
all i had to do i wouldn't i wouldn't
have called but
all i had to do was call him he's gone
yeah i did that
he's but
what's that he's a crazy before you
don't care about jail
he decided like yeah you know what i
bugged you long enough it's been like
three years
yeah he didn't stop buddy here ever once
gotcha yeah
you can say it i went long periods of
time oh you know what he did call me
once
after i had
he called me from there and was like i'm
gonna put you as my emergency contact
i'm like what does that [ __ ] mean
we're divorced
it's been like years and you're like
well in case something happens to me i
go oh now i gotta bury your ass too no
call somebody else i'm not doing that
take me out
i was like i'm not i'm i don't want
sucks that's so cool
yeah but he's he's now i know i couldn't
even be friends with him so it's like no
no i'm good
so where did drugs come in for him was
he on charges like holy probably his
whole life on drugs
oh when we like did that feed into his
crazy or would he have been like crazy
well he i started not liking him
and that's why i thought he was doing
drugs
no i think he was talking
talking about like drugs with you guys
no no no no
period just like drunk
triggered his
that's the guy you don't want to
encounter
and
he didn't do drugs news with you mm-hmm
i didn't know he spoke tweet apparently
told me the job yeah he spoke to me all
the time i didn't know he smoked weed i
just thought i was allowed in this
soldering iron
yeah cause you're smoking bowls i had no
idea yeah that was pretty cool uh
because they allowed him to smoke weed
anything else he couldn't he wasn't
allowed
i had no idea he was speaking they
probably wanted him on on weeds yeah
yeah smoke as much weed as possible
yeah
but he'd start doing drugs until that's
why you guys broke up yeah
yeah then he started yeah that's how you
do it he was like a recovering addict
right now
yeah but you were doing drugs no no no
no you were you you had already had a
drug you got with him when i was what
age like ten
nine
i left ten years on second stream yeah
she stopped doing drugs when i was about
six yes sort of no she's she's
recovering addicts getting together and
he gets back on what you're saying but
like years later right if you guys
really were five years before you
started [ __ ] up yeah damn
that's crazy and my dad
of course yeah because you knew i wasn't
going to put up with that yeah there was
no way there was no [ __ ] way
and then like little [ __ ] before like
like oh this fucker's doing dope again
um
he started like doing weird [ __ ]
like putting himself
or maybe he just didn't hide it from me
no more because i didn't ask him where
he went you know you're a grown man
we'll be back when you're back
those people yeah
but he just started to start acting
could he have been living a double life
the whole time maybe oh yeah probably
yeah it's not really double life no it's
just kids
with you guys yeah yeah but i didn't
question them so i didn't know you know
those gang banger movies you see like
how do you go home when you just have a
life that's exactly what was happening
because there was kind of a job
you built a bit well when he had a job
he was like a professor right he was
trying to be a he
he was he couldn't teach you anything
like he could take the part completely a
tv and put it right back together
back together
would you build that was he like real
like uh if you were to give him talking
about like race or politics would you
start calling he never talked about that
he never talked about that yeah we
haven't talked about that yeah
ever that was just like friends it
wasn't really his ideals i was just like
at
i didn't know him outside of being his
kid so i never really experienced it and
john was not here so he didn't really
ask him what they talked about
your child like them [ __ ] yeah they love
each other yeah i have pictures of him
on jon's shoulders
so that's kind of a good barometer he
was great he was cool yeah he was cool
he just wasn't just
i think when he finally couldn't get a
job and after all the schooling he
started [ __ ] up yeah you just gave up
you think he gave up really like well i
[ __ ] up too much to come back
because he was trying for years trying
to get a job always waking up in the
morning interviews interviews interviews
trying to get like he's a [ __ ] genius
while going to school yeah go to school
the whole time getting all these degrees
all the way to the last time i saw it
was at school
in college he was probably getting a
different degree because he was like
well they won't hire me in this field
did he have a bunch of drug charges
well both they're all assault violence
assault robberies and [ __ ] that happens
with weaker [ __ ]
yeah except this one's like
advanced and advanced
he was really
uh he was awesome i mean he was so
[ __ ] cool yeah until he's stalking
you he didn't know that until he started
being a weirdo
yeah yeah that's it well like when he
started stalking me i um
i started taking remember i was going to
go
i forgot the name of the martial arts
like there's no way i'm going to beat
him but i'm going to take an eyeball
something's going to be messed up on him
yeah that scared the [ __ ] out of it yeah
yeah like right now i've seen i talked
about how many times she'll [ __ ] do
that [ __ ]
right now i did mess up
you and thomas's dad were real physical
yeah
he just like
you made me bleed around he broke the
door
instead of hurting me he broke the door
which is still stupid but
yeah he broke the door yeah i [ __ ] his
face up i made him bleed i was mad
well at least he didn't no he didn't he
would never he would never
a kid or a woman he would never touch no
he's that guy and him and your dad never
bought cats
no hell no because he knows that's my
dad and i would be pissed he once asked
me to beat his ass
[Music]
my dad got in that fight where i stopped
talking to him
when i came home he said why are you
crying like oh [ __ ] i better tell him
not to do anything because i know he's
gonna go over there and [ __ ] kick the
door down that's my dad but that's
awesome
he just disciplined this [ __ ] kid for
talking [ __ ] it's not his fault i was
just upset so i knew i was like it's my
fault even though he pissed me off
i don't want anything to happen
his dad knew my ex-husband before i knew
my ex
okay
[Music]
and i heard his nickname a bunch of
places and they go it's up to something
your dad could have like hated him for
that right that was his friend my dad
like must have put out that jailbird my
dad's a funny [ __ ] he's like
i don't like her taking you to [ __ ]
prison to see him
and then she would get mad at her about
that he had every right to but he wasn't
even there with the [ __ ] better oh
yeah we went to court over there yeah
what's the [ __ ] matter for him like
he was never even in prison he never
showed me up how long was he in prison
for when you guys were together long
enough
no
he was in prison for 16 17 of those
years like he went to jail oh yeah he
started at like 12 or 13 years
five years you so you were together for
like five years oh she had like six
seven
no i would say five years and he was in
jail for two of them he was in jail for
two okay that'd be more than that yeah
because you get married right away
no but still she what did he get where
did he go to jail for um
about two or three four months yeah
okay yeah when he's claiming to be clean
right
well he probably wasn't cleaning no
probably not
i i know what you're saying but for him
it's like oh he's gonna get about two i
don't get a violation
but he didn't get a violation he got a
new charge yeah
he's such a [ __ ] felon
oh for sure yeah he's that guy
yeah he's one of those guys
but it's like i feel like he's one of
those people like
what's up guys yeah i'm happy to be home
type of dudes
he's that guy 100 oh he's a gladiator
you're just born around he's more than
wrong
he told me so much crazy [ __ ] but uh but
that that guy ended up dying like a
month later in a police chase oh yeah
well i thought that guy was just [ __ ]
[ __ ] no he died jesus christ she did
you know what's crazy crazy ass thing i
saw a picture the other day my uncle
john's best friends and like their group
huh all of them they're all dead all the
military ones
chris
oh that's right
my uncle john had like a group of
friends
with me
a group of friends where i smoked my
first ball of my life was with chris
chris banghart was so crazy that was
cool that's what it was so cool oh john
pepper's dog is bigger [ __ ]
but
he died
so crazy ass crazy ass [ __ ]
you already know and some [ __ ] happened
at the meat factory and he died yeah i
remember i told you crazy yeah that was
horrible and then john called me like
three months before john died and his
friend jimmy got killed yeah because he
started tweaking
and someone stabbed him in half with the
[ __ ] samurai sword and a [ __ ] i
thought they shot him no he got shakes
he got shaken
[Music]
yeah damn yeah
that was horrible
some conviction paul paul
yeah damn yeah okay it's just a trip
because streams appeared
yeah and the job ass was like dude
you [ __ ] serious
i knew all these guys would you say like
you grew up one more second right
like thomas talks about his friends that
he grew up
and he's like
look around the friends i grew up with
it doesn't look great a lot of them are
on drugs or happening [ __ ] like that
kind of [ __ ] up would you say drugs
never said affected your generation of
course yeah oh my god yes yeah uh like
my
people that i would like grew up with
that
did drugs well they're probably still
doing drugs but then for a long time you
can definitely see
you could definitely see the effects
that that that [ __ ] had on them
they're never the thing their brains are
like like holes in them they their teeth
are all grounded down
they just look like they're my age and
i'll be what 51 and they look like
they're in their 70s 80s easy is that
still is it are well you know meth
every day or is it um yeah probably yeah
yeah every time you see it you don't
know the [ __ ] walk in you know like
that was [ __ ] up
you could tell a lot like there are
mannerisms that they're on dope yeah
just because i i remember i was like six
and you know
oh i had like nine
and we were driving and i was in the
backseat i'm still observing the [ __ ]
reading everything that's not really
learning how to read was like reading
everything i see and [ __ ]
and there was this motorcycle guy a guy
on the motorcycle in front of us no
shirt and he's sitting there just
scratching his bowl oh just
and then that might have been something
else you said you're like
look at this guy he is tweaking looking
he won't stop and saw me just kept
scratching the sink spot his whole back
was like scratched red like yeah that
guy is john drugs huh and that's when i
started realizing like
manners and [ __ ] tweakers and [ __ ]
that you can see and my dad's friends
[Music]
it's really it's very very strange it's
like
i know my dad's on drugs
oh his jaw sticks out
oh [ __ ] dude
you guys that i could see on his [ __ ]
base sweating and [ __ ] but i think it's
my little sister elizabeth
that's just naturally she should like
sit there just
same thing grace got it
my dad's all these dude kids all have
like i do too i'll be sitting like this
yeah but you're not like but i'm not on
drugs but i like this
that's very weird i do it too it's
sharing points now that's how you
[ __ ] tweeted
yeah because he did it for so long and
it's a habit but i could tell
ready
we talked about it where he almost got
eaten by oh the cougar we did tell you
about it oh yeah
i don't think we actually got to that i
used i could have swear we have let's do
the faster version in case we have them
sorry okay i got the faster version we
were all inside
the movie we were watching i don't know
because he had the radio on so loud
remember you played thrash metal
but over yeah you were watching it but
you couldn't hear it
well i heard that dad he was playing
some like metallica like super super
loud we couldn't hear [ __ ] who were up
in the mountains so you could play your
music
and all of a sudden
all right i was picturing a picture of
the shoe character
anyway
anyway so
i was stoned i didn't know that but i
was stoned so i was just sitting there
awake with yeah
loud ass music
we forgot that he went outside
like no because you're gonna take it i'm
not i swear my life i'm not taken you
will have it right back get this one
no because i'm going to get loaded and i
don't want to be loaded
that is a water vape
it's a hydration thing your life would
be yeah
his eyes are bugged out of his head and
he's screaming at me and and the sister
calling us [ __ ]
that he was locked in the chicken coop
this whole time
with a mountain lion
yeah it kept him behind him because the
mountain lion got all the chicken so he
went up i don't know why he needed to go
up there and get the chicken food
like leave it who cares there's no
chickens left
he went in there to get it and the lion
went in he was waiting for that [ __ ]
wine
who did i get my story telling skills
way yeah yeah
he picked up the water trough and put it
in between him i didn't know what it was
i remember he said he grabbed something
yeah it's like a water truck
yeah
and he went to he picked it up and then
the thing attacked him like he was
trying to get him and then he kind of
like he's all scratched
but now
he fought it like he punched in the
[ __ ] mouth he told me yeah
he said he's holding he's like crap
and then came back at his ass and then
he said it smelled if you the thing that
made him turn around and just smell all
of a sudden like an animal
like
like
that's something you wouldn't think
about yeah so he turned around he turned
around like he's a prisoner though so
he's hiding the senses
for death and so um
where the where the chicken coop it was
like on a really high slant like a hill
and the house was down there so he just
jumped off of the mountain
and came flying into the
living room
screaming at him and that was when once
his face and the other dudes went out
with guns looking for that mountain lion
because the coat had just got eaten the
golden got the gokai
they just left the head and changed see
i love it [ __ ] you guys my memory is on
point man
it was just like all jurassic park ahead
the head broke up the handshake
no mine ate the whole body i thought
this [ __ ] thing off with his hands
bought it
and she's over here i
[Applause]
at least i didn't just give up and just
let her let him kill me whatever no i
was gonna fight
damn you described that pretty well
thank you yeah but he told me exactly
what happened pretty much what she said
but i i can imagine the intensity and
the sound of his back can change [ __ ]
chain but he's sitting there screaming
for men for 30 minutes
[Music]
and i didn't hear him screaming whenever
he walked off he came in
you [ __ ] [ __ ] he started crossing
screaming yeah
he never did that he never called he
never fought
nothing never
he was he had she had blood yeah he had
blood like bruce lee and [ __ ]
dragon he had blood scratches did he die
he didn't die but he was like ripped
over
like like the thing just placed his body
and just touched it yeah it was
unbelievable shirt sweating
sweating hard as [ __ ]
and i remember i like and i'm sitting
there listening and tell the story
i thought it was funny but wait it's not
like he was lying the [ __ ] chicken
drum well i was high so
but he says he was with it like this for
20 minutes fighting it off
yeah and he was against the chain
like this against the feds trying not to
get eaten in the corner and he said
every once alone he would smack the [ __ ]
out of it i mean he punched a mountain
lion enough to get it scared and he said
what he did is he [ __ ] twist turned
and he was jerking it went out closed
the gates ran it away jumped off the
mountain yeah yeah he jumped about 10 15
feet down down boom breaks his ankle my
[Laughter]
see that's exactly the story
i sold
yeah that was that was it wasn't it was
funny but it wasn't funny he wasn't yeah
he was scared for his life he was scared
but yeah he was actually scared
i could see it on his face that
yo you look
frightened and i've never seen you like
scared 20 minutes or so like if you hit
a heavy bag for a minute fighting off
the mountain lion from at least he told
us he was out there he's like i've been
screaming for 20 minutes
and he said they're screaming for help
the whole time that everybody's got guns
in the house uh-huh
he can see the house can't get our
attention because toy story no that
music was awesome i guess music
story
that's exactly there
wow
that was amazing he was waiting to use
[Music]
well i like to believe that that
mountain was a black panther black in
the past life and was trying to get
revenge on the white race
or one of these [ __ ]
the spirit of two spirit of [ __ ]
fox father
for a black man that was in there like
oh my goodness
i already got that racist goal yesterday
i got all these other [ __ ]
that's how i like to imagine it we need
a cartoon
i like to imagine that mountain lion
came in his [ __ ] pen
you turned around smiled at him
i've been waiting for that yeah exactly
exactly but call me what
yeah but he wasn't a racist piece of
[ __ ]
just in jail outside was
everything was wrong my best friend was
plugging black
very fine but his dad was the cop right
yeah fun
that's crazy
[Music]
my friend i won't say what state
one of my friends
big
trapper dudes sells metric units
a month uh
he sells thousands of houses yeah
gets with this girl i've already got
with her
it's it's a state in the midwest anyway
it doesn't matter
god with her
like yeah she's cool
right now but that was like 10 years ago
i just thought it was playing like you
are the ultimate person to not be around
any kind of law enforcement
and now you gotta meet this guy on like
sunday dinners [ __ ] this is a
walter white she sure is
and he did it for years and years and
years he's kind of smart i mean that
does yeah he's not he's so no more but
it was pretty good i i couldn't believe
what he told me let's say that but
you're a [ __ ] mother
there's no way that you found one random
girl at a store
better than her dad the guy that put you
in prison shut the [ __ ] up
then went to prison so i hope it worked
out in his benefit
either he's a masterminder as a [ __ ]
meets a dear cop yeah all right very
common no mortgage fans that's pretty
sick
um
so yeah that's what happened mariposa
glad you remember it correct
okay
i remember stuff i choose to remember
stuff and i choose to not read it she
said i remember stuff
like
keenan and kell when he's reading i know
some of these words i don't even know
from good bird i've never seen
good burger so i think you're on transit
[ __ ]
no
yes you will no
no i was not if it was before i was
seven years old you were on drugs at the
time no they're not the murderer came up
from 95. i was not six years old
i am correct you are not going to next
timelines
all the time i go watching that come out
oh
because it's funnier to me
let's say she was in the peace corps
maybe that's a nice yeah you're in the
peace corps piece of cocaine
on top of a [ __ ] torch
sorry
i have never smoked speed in my life i
am [ __ ] i have never injected speed
in my life yet
no when i get to a certain age
when i get to a certain age if i'm still
alive i'm doing heroin
that's where you got that she'd get this
for me
i've been saying this [ __ ] for years i'm
interested because doesn't it look like
it looks like it would be fun yeah
i've seen many people don't [ __ ] a house
[ __ ] a car we don't even know that yeah
nope
i mean if i od i mean it's not gonna who
cares you know i just want to be
weightless and float over a city
it sounds like everyone could be that
thing to help me do that
i don't know
damn it youtube is gonna be monetized
did you probably um
just cut it out but next question
where were you doing all of these drugs
well i don't
say where were you doing you said i was
high at the time
where were you sleeping
where were you sneaking on the smoking
weed at
this at home oh well yeah i did it well
outside where you guys couldn't see it
when you sold a cigarette or something
sure i'm saying i'm asking because i
always saw it she was doing germans for
your kids
where i was around it's convenient if
you're smoking cigarettes oh yeah then
it's not that far were you smoking
meth no
i okay
i did you were cranking with red no i
was not
no i was not
i remember the last time i did remember
i told you that story yeah you stared in
the mirror
and we lived in fresno then call this
that was the last time i told you i
cracked my [ __ ] head open no i was on
your your memory is garbage my memory is
not hard
you quit drugs because of the crack no
no
you know what else you know what else
you told me that and i talked about it
huh i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about goodbye
are we doing this now this is what we're
doing i'm going to do [ __ ] tech tech
that's my team i ain't even possible
anymore i'm talking about i'm going to
talk
thomas cracked his head open you were
providing parental supervision the next
morning wasn't too scared
yeah that was stuff that said
i was not drunk i was just an [ __ ]
well how many times no i've never did
drugs with that with that guy
ever i think i swallowed a weed with him
because he used to smoke a lot of weight
too give me two more seconds all right
maybe we did nothing
all right
no i didn't even know he was doing that
he thought he was crazy you know what's
crazy is he was crazy you can't tell
[ __ ] are doing drugs in your
relationship with him and you know drugs
i think you are oblivious and we're a
selfish ass [ __ ] to not pay
attention to all the [ __ ] i
never give a [ __ ] yeah that's crazy
isn't that like racist
right now bleep out you didn't know
something something oh
i just said someone's name i could not
have that on there just leave that thank
you in the edit thank you
um you didn't know peter was on drugs
i don't like that name we'll pick a
different name um
i was about to say
[Music]
spin that every time yeah no
does this make her think her memory
sucks so bad you said it no i did not it
was like rally balls i swear i didn't
call you i cut my hand on your fence on
your screen remember the paper bag
extension with adam sandler and david
spader work at the pants store
the snl skin i don't remember where
chris farley plays the big [ __ ]
manager no plays the manager i remember
that one they're all like sitting here
she's already telling me she remembers
she can't remember good ass [ __ ]
snails against
26 years ago
we expect you to remember how expected
you remember everything
okay i have the next question
it's back when you remember it was but
i'm cheating
you said you're gonna be nice
um
so
the first time you laid hands on
the first time you gouged my eye all
right my next question you were doing
drugs when you smoked a cigarette that
was an actual question because i don't
know i don't consider weak drugs mom
when you were smoking methamphetamines i
was not smoking that i've never smoked
craig your honor here saying okay
objection
let's just
let's call it cbd meth like
no
no we're not calling it any of that
because i didn't i wasn't doing it
back when you were doing hardcore drugs
with my dad okay that was that was yeah
okay let me worry a difference sorry man
and i broke up with your dad in 1991
okay
mom i was 20 years
yeah you were three years old when i
left that's only two years
so first off your mouth i'm sorry crazy
i remember i was three years old at
least because i can fully remember the
day i remember the day it was april 30th
1992.
i'm sorry thank you sorry thank you uh
thank you yeah okay that sounds great
i remember i was the least three
zach didn't get to go to school yet
and that was even like the date that um
i think we found out something's wrong
with mia
that that was a really shitty date for
me for a long time even though it's like
my cousin yeah me and him
me and the soccer player
we found out something um yeah yeah
on april 30th
yeah
wow i'm [ __ ] kidding oh i was like
i am kidding one time i remind this
child it was like yo i ain't gonna live
and then she did not live and her name
was mia and she would have been my
sister and i was making my part of it
because because you're an [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i wanted to make it funny
and then um do the terminator one yeah
i i get it
i get it continue april 30th is the day
you left my dad yeah okay
you found audrey's tweet again no no we
got a huge fight
no why was not oh my god dude
it's crazy because i've heard all these
stories before she told me when i was on
drugs
[Applause]
[Music]
i was still smoking weed
okay so you were smoking when you did do
drugs and i didn't see it you guys were
doing it in the room or outside where i
couldn't see it that was my question i
was hoping for a child i just in the
bathroom i set up
i thought whatever i used to do this
so this is the time where you could do
that were you doing drugs [ __ ]
we all know she used to do drugs like i
wasn't
it was 1985 but it's not 1991. oh you're
right it was 92 2006.
[ __ ] late 1900s
well you had to make it all crazy like
some [ __ ]
documentary people are doing cbd math do
you do it like often like how do you
like
is it like a two to every two to three
hours you gotta keep going or is it like
you're set for like every week
math is not it's the best joke because
it's the cheapest and last one
oh it does last long yeah and i okay so
when i did i did do that for a while not
a long time but a while and i didn't
like it i did not like it it was very um
the come down was horrible yeah it
sounds horrible across the board i can't
understand why people do it yeah but
when you when you first do it you feel
of course like any you know upper you
feel like invincible you know you could
do anything you could do whatever
and then for like me i'm super sensitive
to that [ __ ] so one line would keep me
up for days and i was like this is
[ __ ]
and measure that no no i should be most
tweakers most tweakers then would just
stay home
you know
before they got so bad they had to go
out to get money to get drugs because
you're paranoid that your people already
know you're tweaking or not yes and you
just don't want to be around people it
kind of just makes you so you're all
fired up and haven't got to go but you
don't want it i used to draw a lot i
used to draw a lot and i used to um
like
he wasn't even around
that's a good one
what did you draw just
um just whatever
yeah people
people things like realistic yeah
realistic um i drew a really cool
picture of jim morrison once it took me
like three days to do it not like loaded
days but like three days because
it was pretty cool and then i threw it
away oh damn
no it's just like i didn't want oil to
see it
that's what the very good yeah of course
does the paranoia kick in right away or
does it take
and then it's not and it's like why
because i have friends that just stayed
up i'm like [ __ ] go to sleep they would
just be sitting on like on a bed like
staring out the window laughing
and i'm like walking in like what in the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
okay
you could just tell they've been up for
days too just their brains not working
no more
like how on the east coast like they say
the crack happened
you know and swept through new york city
and everything
did mrsa california it had the crack
epidemic and then the method like
and we're 10 years behind remember
i don't remember crack being prevalent
but meth and um
crying pcp
um yeah because when you guys say this
like literally never once did i ever
think like this was tweaking i never
even probably said the word i never even
wasn't even saying cracked out yeah i've
never even like heads it's mexicans
don't really do crack
they do they go back they do
yeah the majority of mexican drug users
are smoking meth yeah that's what i just
like the majority of white dudes that
smoke weed but this generation no but
this generation in fact
a lot of pills and a lot of fentanyl and
[ __ ] like that when i moved to the
place where i live now
within one month three every weekend
this group of teenagers were dying from
from um
no one one friend died and then the
following weekend the other friend died
and i was like holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
all the same stash dummies yeah can't
figure out that is the stash they were
drinking and taking xanax
oh yeah yeah
young young kids
do pills
it was sad the thing is for me that i
want to push into people's eggs i used
to tell this to my friends all the time
because now that i'm getting older it's
different
you can do pills and drugs just remember
if you [ __ ] die
in 10 years
you're going to be dead for 10 years
like you ever think about this
i know it sounds crazy so so stunned but
it sounds so simple sounds stupid
think of your best friend
and think of 30 years from now imagine
them dying right now and going wow in 30
years you were dead like 21.
i'm 50.
you know yeah since you've been gone
through that now i'm i get that but i'm
saying for [ __ ] out there to do
pills oh yeah think about that right now
yeah yeah it's weird really weird it's
weird because i have like followers that
are dead dude you know what [ __ ] we've
done since you've been gone
how much [ __ ] you didn't even get to see
an iphone come out [ __ ] you saw
nothing nothing cool your team is
actually a good team now
like this is uh that's why i always
think like during the third year i used
to tell us martin when he was selling
meth i'm like well if you go to prison
manage that in 15 years
you're going to be just where you're at
now
but in 15 years yeah that's why you see
45 girls walking around looking for like
bro you're not 20. yeah what are you
doing that they're aging
their age stops when they go in there
that's what i mean so with the drugs
we're talking about pills
that's what i'm saying like
think about it every time you take pills
that could be it
that's all
it could be over [ __ ] you know you your
homies should go man it's that cool
back to what i was doing right that's
all you are
so that's the thing to think about while
doing hard drugs
or just don't do them
they're not worth they're not that cool
hard drugs are cool but
they're not that i've done hard drugs i
like
walking into the warehouse going damn
this is crazy that's way cooler than
doing hard drugs like
that's tight of course accomplishes some
[ __ ] it's way cooler because i swear
i've done a lot of drugs they're fun but
they wear off
it's a cop ops you're feeling good yeah
they're cool i mean i'm not going to say
they're not tight i like psychedelics
uh that's not drugs to me yeah that's
not true not hard
doing coke all the time bro if you gotta
if you gotta add [ __ ] and cook [ __ ] and
just this [ __ ] yeah that's just
something yeah it's a weird message to
deliver to a teenager
like there is certain [ __ ] like me that
becomes okay once you're an adult you
can kind of you like kind of earn that
privilege even like alcohol like you
earn the right to have that that's one
of the things you may get to be an adult
cool now you can manage that
and i want to like be true to myself i'm
expressing that because i don't want my
kids like smoking meat even i want to i
don't want you doing anything that's
like i don't want you having any habits
while you're a kid
keep that clean because
okay okay i know your daughter's 14
right okay so
next year
a year from now two years from now you
find out she's smoking me
what are you gonna do
there's nothing you really can do we
need my soundboard but yeah i mean
there's gunshots
what are you gonna do that's the warning
i don't want to be a [ __ ] hypocrite
and i want it to be understood that
there's there is a difference in life
between being an adult and being a kid
and there is [ __ ] that will [ __ ] your
life up that you can do as a kid that
will [ __ ] you up as an adult
and you can make choices now that will
set you on a path for a horrible life
okay i'm not trying to like you know oh
yeah it's teenage smoking weed do it
everybody do it no but i do remember
the first time i smoked i was like 12.
and
i'm going to be 51 and i don't smoke a
lot but i do still smoke
when i was that age i had a lot of
issues that helped me get through a lot
of my issues
it's like i think if it literally is
like an internal theater test constantly
like that's really how i interface with
it i i really for the same reasons like
i don't feel like i need anything really
outside of it to manage to keep me
balanced or level but i made that
decision like really as an adult
you know that's what that's just what i
wanted but then you really can't go by
me because i had my my daughter when i
was 16 so yeah i'm not a good couple no
no
i'm not a good example well i didn't
well i just say you know
when you're raising kids don't forget
the best advice i can give you is don't
forget what you were thinking what
you're doing at their age yes
and then you'll understand like what the
hell they're like why they're crying
because they don't even know why they're
crying why did you cry when you were
that age that was really easy you were
very you and your sister were very very
easy yeah that [ __ ] happened his way all
right
rocco's a little more um it's different
he's like raising his ass like
well with rocco i can't think because i
pay so much more attention with rocco
i could tell when he's in bamboo i could
tell when someone pissed him off i can
tell when he's not feeling good i could
just look at him and i could tell
but that's because i
it was me and rocco for a very very very
long time you know
and i had no really no distractions just
work but i tried to like okay the other
two
kind of [ __ ] to bed on that one yeah
but this one i'm gonna do a different
he's a cool kid he's very very good he's
flirting yeah he's a pretty cool kid
you know he could be annoying but
yes he can
right now watch when he's watching he
could be bent over shaking his
ass
cause he's been doing that lately my
brother's just a [ __ ] internet kid
he's a mess right he's a man there's a
thing where people just are walking
he'll come in those things and just
start well i do that yeah
i just do stupid [ __ ] when i walk in
rooms because it makes me
no
i was in the house and all of a sudden
it felt like someone was tearing down
the [ __ ] house and i call rock i'm
like where are you he goes i want to
walk why i'm like it sounds like
someone's tearing down the house this
[ __ ] is on the [ __ ] roof jumping
up and down
on my part of the ceiling yes
i thought the [ __ ] house was being
like
through the house and it's this jackass
on the roof and he lied until he was
gone yeah he told me that that's good i
like that no it's like the end of uh
it's like the end of
come on
mega [ __ ]
mud pie
drop down
yeah that was a horror that's me
to rocco for him [ __ ] with you
that's how i feel
and then i get in my car and i leave
just like she did
yeah yeah
that's how i that's how i feel you're
the new dad that was like what are you
doing you got the [ __ ] babysitter in
the tree
you're the babysitter always now
and bronco is the little girl
with the missing tooth and your drop
dead fred no
ma'am cakes i'm leaving and i'm happy
going yeah
right bronco no i don't think i have a
comparison
because everyone's confused now well i
guess i'll be i'll be miss honey and
raccoons steal his ass and he moves down
to l.a
away from lady from cheers
i look like carla are you trying to say
that
in the movie you're the lady that she
lives with and i'm gonna
it used to be this trench pole and she
called it that was really funny
that's funny
i i did two skittles and she threw me
out the window not having his so that's
what i was like and the chokie
oh i've said this before the choking
start just beating my ass
this is i it's just reminding me i've
said this before somewhere
okay on to my next question oh you're
done
are you ready nope your next question
no it's perfect sorry
i like it
what's your no
no no
no
[Music]
twice
yeah that gives you the right though
kind of that's what it was i should beat
this [ __ ] out of me you never go
he is a kid
exactly thank you good timing did you
ever go [ __ ] maybe that's just slow
because it slowed down
no
as you're like
honestly maybe i should i don't remember
having to hit you like really one time
you are [ __ ] kids ugh
one time yeah he was a good kid
plus he was terrified right i didn't
have to [ __ ] with him too much like his
sister she tried me a little bit more
but you know she's a girl
and all he had to do was see that and he
was like no no you
not that know
no he wasn't i mean he did the sneaky
[ __ ] he did a lot of sneaking
what
really
tell me
you know oh god
i'm gonna say stuff and you're gonna
deny it so why am i gonna even bother
for we for everything i'm gonna say
something you guys in your memory [ __ ]
and you're gonna deny it but if it's
true i won't say it's true
okay so you really think that i didn't
know what you were doing when you were
taking people into your room closing the
door
uh yeah mom you know why because there
was only one person i ever did that with
it was andrew bacon i did it once yeah
exactly what situation you're talking
about i knew exactly what you were
talking about you're saying you're being
sneaky with the weed being sneaky with
oh sneaky with all kinds of stuff
with what
i'm not thinking of anything i know
it's gonna be two weeks from now she's
like oh gee watch i got you full yeah i
got one of you every time i take a
stupid picture of ogo
i got you for watch i got you you've
been saved for five years
andrew bacon all right is the only
person i ever let into the house while
you were there
because we played basketball together
she probably just thinks you get a
passport real quick i saw him a 10
second i sold him a 10 sec he went like
this as he went like this i threw my
whole sack like this because i heard her
ass [ __ ] jurassic park ass down the
hallway and i [ __ ] threw my backpack
i'm in my bag of weed as it threw my bag
of weed it went
into my closet and went
[ __ ] yeah good [ __ ] as it hit she walked
in and go get out of here
and i stood there and you said the other
side of the bed you go
what are you doing i don't know knows
something's up but she can't prove [ __ ]
and that was it okay and she knew
something was up
but she said you're being yeah she's
being all sneaky
i don't remember that was the only
person i've ever seen
so i'll think of something i was so
cautious
i thought you know what if she's doing
laundry and she's not going to pay
attention to me and you come in real
quick
like one
unit over i'm like ah she knows andrew
he always comes up here you're such a
good kid though i'm so suspicious
exactly because he never did that before
i haven't had kids in my room a million
times playing gta but he was like just
come in and just close the door like the
one time he was trying to he wasn't
going to school he gets up she's leaving
he gets up to leave and this kid always
with his [ __ ] hair he walks out and
his hair is
[ __ ] up on one side and i'm like hey
man your hair's off i don't care
okay so that's when i went in and closed
your window
yeah but they guess i took that head but
you still broke the [ __ ] door getting
in that was a whole nother day it still
happened
don't don't kick the door don't kick the
door i'm gonna get the door don't kick
the door in
i'm gonna break it down don't break the
[ __ ] house
who paid for the door it doesn't matter
am afraid
this guy called because i had a tennis
act
but none of our other guys were off of
work they were all out of high school
they weren't off at work did something
need yet all so i didn't have no more
weed and i was about to re-up i had
money but nobody to buy weed or a ride
and hoover wasn't real and i knew if i
had a phone
what was i really going to do called
weed maps
as a child
so she thinks she [ __ ] got me stuck
up 250 [ __ ] times came back in the
house she's like that one time i gotcha
get the [ __ ] out i still got you i'm
gonna get out of here all right she's
gonna get back up huh you knew something
wait what what happened you wouldn't
leave your [ __ ] uploaded
someone knew that one time you walked by
i don't think i got it
all right well let me walk six feet all
right i'm gonna get it anyway and i
would just sleep in my closet
because i was like i have been inside
yeah and you know that i can't sleep i
couldn't sleep back then i'd be until
like 5 30 and i had to get up at 7 to go
to school
i can't do this
and there would be times where i would
like no i'm going to sleep i could
cosplay sleeping in the grass outside
but i think she might smoke a cigarette
and find me some random time
she sees a dog run by why is there a dog
something something's gonna happen so
that's why
um
so when you're beating this [ __ ] did you
ever think i was should i remind you
this kid that
is this really your question it says it
this is really with quotations yeah
because i think it's funny
i think it's funny to ask questions that
are so like oh god oh it's a real
question that makes me laugh
so you're looking for like a yes or no
answer here yeah
did you ever watch from damn right
in his ass
i don't know man you're like 30
something years old i'm asking you
eight so she thinks it's still hurting
but he used to hurt yeah
yes or no did you think once you go down
sure
so that means no you just say no
half a beer yeah i don't drink half a
beer no this is my second one right here
is it yeah and plus that's probably like
because you're blowing this [ __ ]
directly at me
so far it's a little foggy in here we
are at 121.
god damn you're good what is it i just
checked yeah is it really good it's 122.
that's incredible bro every time
every single time i get that right you
gotta tell the truth
let's do that that's god speaking
through this that's god speaking through
the sound word that's not what is
referred to i'm gonna use it as that
every time i hit that number you gotta
tell the truth now did you
when is it gonna be funnier to me
[ __ ] man you had your time
it was funny
no man
just go over here just hang out yeah
don't worry i mean the show won't be
ruined no really can i go because of
course you can go i'm kidding
ready and now
yo what's up guys welcome to the mid
roll ad read and we're introducing a new
sponsor and this is from our friends
seek geek if you don't know what sea
geek is guys this is an app that lets
you buy tickets to concerts sporting
events everything you get the best deals
possible i actually if you've seen my
snapchat you've actually seen me use
this when i went to the raider game and
i went to the laker game really quick
story about sea geek one time me and my
friend jerem from merced tried to get
tickets rosie got him for us on seek
geek like 40 these are not going to be
good tickets me and him had our own
private spot we got the vip tickets when
tickets don't get sold they go fast for
cheap when the game's about to start
that's what sea geek's here for the
green dot means good and we did good so
with that being said guys marty and i
are super proud to announce that right
now code dope as usual when you use seek
geek app the code dobesu will get you 20
off of anything you buy any ticket any
concert event any sporting event any
festival everything so we are super
proud to announce that we have teamed up
with seatgeek and right now if you go to
their app and use our checkout code
which is dope as usual you get 20 off of
anything you go to and like i said from
personal experience from personal use
this is the app that rosie and i use for
all of our tickets so whether you're
going to watch a concert or you're going
to go watch the finals here in a couple
weeks remember to use our code on the
seekee gap that's dope as usual for 20
off your very first purchase as always
guys thank you so much for supporting
the brands that support us back to the
episode
so my mom stopped the show she had to go
to the bathroom
and we might have had some technical
difficulties we don't know at this point
in time
but marty is just doing you know what
marty's supposed to do he's changing the
camera battery takes a step
steps on one cord and it unplugs our
power source
and it looks like the audio did not save
now because it shut off a meet randomly
i don't know what happened and marty's
angle it says it did not record but it
shows footage
yeah that sounds sounds about right
right yeah his usual podcast sounds like
we get played it sounds like my mom
would do that to an oscar sounds like
she would do some [ __ ] i was in a
psychotic rage remember yeah marty uh
i could tell on the inside marty's
beating the [ __ ] out of himself like
yeah just [ __ ] it all up you really
[ __ ] so there could be a possibility
that the first half of this episode
sounds a little like this because we had
to use the cameras but it probably
sounds like this and i'm going to say it
does
don't worry
yeah we're going to get it done
we're good but just in case this is us
letting you know why
okay we're going to be strapping these
[ __ ] power strips up to the walls
yeah or something yes [ __ ] this that
can't happen again
it's never happened in all the seasons i
mean all the episodes marty you step on
one chord and it just happens to go dink
and um yeah it was the switch the red
switch on the power strip the little
corner your air max clips the little
[ __ ] switch
that's it
just
are you happy
all right back to what i was saying i
don't remember because we stopped so
let's see oh
yeah i don't remember you got to my
topic my next one ready it's a story oh
yeah then you said hell when i have to
go to the bathroom
story i want to hear from you what i've
never heard it so i want to hear from
you what's the first fight you ever got
into that wasn't with your siblings
hold up
who's the first person you ever beat up
i should say
like full-on like just fight
um
[Music]
some
some chick in my ninth grade i was in
ninth grade
okay yeah all right og
that was my first thanks oh gee
yeah fool [ __ ] the [ __ ] wasn't like
ninth grade a
ninth grade a that's what you just said
to me some big
big end punched me and i then beat the
hell at her why did this happen because
she was dating my well can me and my
boyfriend broke up yes there's a story
behind it i said to ask me and my
boyfriend had broke up and she was
dating him but he was still coming
around me
and i probably started it a little bit
but it sounds like anyway she just came
up to no because she was dating him
already but she was just being stupid
whatever
anyway
she's just like in school came up to me
and just
clocked me she was big
she was big
yeah so i think she kind of like cuz she
hit me like right here and kind of
knocked me out a little bit but i didn't
fall
and then when i like came to
i was
well what the principal's principles
said that
because i wouldn't stop they were going
to call the cops on me
this is before they used to call the
cops they would just suspend the one
that started the fight
well since she started the fight but i
wouldn't stop we both got suspended
sounds right yeah it's like you're in
the wrong but it sounds right how am i
in the wrong she hit me hold on
you she was in the wrong for hitting you
yeah she shouldn't touch you she should
have known this is what you do if you're
going to beat somebody up make sure you
can whoop their ass not even that
because even though you might be bigger
than them you never know how crazy that
was my boyfriend weirdo
oh my god do you want to tell you the
story or you want to navigate the story
i'm only talking about the facts that
you were presented to anyway the
statement said so i beat the [ __ ] out of
her and then she was mad because i beat
her up okay but
i think she still holds that whole time
source of the story
was not your boyfriend
her boyfriend i would have never hit her
over in this [ __ ] that's not what i'm
saying i just want to know the source of
the story yeah
she hit me first problem she hit me
first but you're the problem with that
problem she hit me first hold on if
someone's in the relationship words back
to me she didn't have to hit me
that's what i'm saying i'm saying before
the fighting say whatever you want just
don't put yourself before the fighting
it's probably your fault no probably i
mean his fault from the beginning yeah
but i mean what does it matter you don't
put
for you if you're going to hit somebody
make sure you stop going back to the
[ __ ] see this is that mercy [ __ ]
i'm trying to present a fact
cares it's been 40 years but won't tell
me and admit that yeah i probably
shouldn't have yeah i probably shouldn't
talk [ __ ] to her but thank you
she asked for that's all she started it
that's it like hey remember how i broke
up that guy i don't like it anymore
well you're with him i don't i don't
like you
i like you now no that has nothing to do
with anything
she put her toy down and somebody else
picked it up from the goodwill and she
went
that was my [ __ ] i gave away i didn't
want it anymore banana you have it i'm
gonna [ __ ] it well there was other stuff
too she's like she was writing [ __ ]
about me on the bathroom wall and i was
like oh this big [ __ ] look at the time
i was like you tell the story but you
only told me it makes you sound better
okay so
okay so me and him broke up the facts
hold on okay so me and him broke up he
started seeing this gargantuan
right
she was like five four no she just
started [ __ ] i was like five times three
if i was real girl i mean i didn't
finish growing i was still like what 14
15 15.
my 15th birthday i got suspended anyway
um
she
was like talking about me and saying
[ __ ] to me about me and of course you
know girls want girls to fight so they
were telling me what she was saying and
i'm like yeah whatever
so we were walking like through you know
you know east campus that big
that big um
in the middle it's for bad kids i never
went there well it was for bad kids when
you
were coming up but when i was it was
just
an east campus and then you you know for
ninth grade and then all the after that
you go to north campus
but um it was like big opening in the
middle where all the lockers were
and um she was walking and i was walking
that way and she i said something her
she says something to me and she came up
and hit me
but this was after the bell rang so
everybody was in their classrooms so
it's just me and her out there fighting
and then like
i guess i went into a crazy rage or some
[ __ ]
but took like two principles to get me
uh well the vice principal and the the
what do you call that guy that the
truant officer yeah him
and then the other
i guess prince i don't know principal he
grabbed her and took her away
and they had to like
gaffle me up it was pretty stupid i was
embarrassed
because when i like i was embarrassed
because when it was over everybody was
out of the classrooms watching us
don't call him stupid don't you ever
call him stupid you're calling me stupid
no that's from [ __ ] forrest gump
what does that have to do with this
right now what i was in my head at the
time
i thought you fighting the girl and i
thought a [ __ ] lieutenant didn't tell
him the [ __ ] is not to call for stupid
anyway so yeah that was that i got
suspended
and
my dad was not mad
yeah okay that's fine that's cool that
was the first part
was you had a fight and i was like yeah
and he was like did you win i was like i
believe so he was like all right
that was the end of it would your dad
smack a [ __ ] too pretty quick
no
it depends on like the situation but no
no
my grandpa was too cool i think yeah no
he nobody wants to fight my grandpa
yeah but he's tight yeah but yeah i
don't have no i don't think i've had
heard of her heard him having a problem
with somebody actually because think
about it because she started it they let
me just walk home
because they're like we're going to call
the cops back in the 50s bro when they
were like yo this was the the mid 80s
shut up they were like let the brown one
walk well no she was brown too [ __ ] yeah
but they they i told them if you
if you're gonna um
let me out
you're gonna let me walk home you better
make sure she's gone because if i see
her outside i'm jumping on her again
you know they're like you need to stop
we're gonna call a cop call the cops
call him
that's how stupid i was i was i was like
yeah it was dumb
were you so mad because she got a hit on
you yeah yeah i thought so i was like
i was mad because she hit me
and then she scratched me
and i was like what the hell are you
gonna hit me and then scratch me i had
like scratches all down my chest and
[ __ ] but and they were like you broke
our nose i was like whatever i don't
care she hit me first what do you want
me to do just let her hit me she's huge
letting her hit me yeah that's true so
were you quicker to fight after that to
fight her against people in general no
no because that scared me
because i because if no one was actually
one of my friends like tried to stop me
and i almost hit her too
but because
my when i was we were fighting i was
trying to kill her i wanted to kill her
and that scared the hell out of me so i
never i didn't fight with years later
put those toys away put those [ __ ]
toys away
she she was scaled back by that point
she was trying to kill you no i wasn't
trying to kill you
but um
that's funny strangle you a little maybe
right now yeah that scared the child it
scared me because that no one was if no
one if they everybody would have stayed
in their classrooms i would have
probably just kept going until damn so
you were just trying to like stomp her
out
jesus christ yeah and that like scared
me mm-hmm
so
as it should and girls face they break
real easy you know they like they they
they're not real they're not
adorable you know you hit them in the
face and [ __ ] just
yeah it's kind of which will find out
right after this commercial as soon as
you saw that i thought yeah
i was thinking of the fight tonight
it did it did scare the hell out of me
because i was like i would have killed
that whoop that girl if no one was there
to stop me
and
we wouldn't have a [ __ ] sibling
jesus christ i got somebody there to
[ __ ] fight with the girl after that i
was like never again like they could say
whatever they want to be i do not care
but they
touched me or put their hands on it at
what point in life did you just start
murking fools
i don't think i've ever killed anyone no
i'm like
i
become a
girl that fights dudes like um no that
that was like thrust upon me you know i
didn't have a choice
and his dad was really the only one that
we would like
box like back and forth with but we were
both kids you know we had no business
doing we had no business
trying to be adults anyways we were both
kids it's such an odd thing to like yo
and i'ma punch my girlfriend
no it wasn't like that he just didn't
like all right you know what i'm insane
you know in general yeah as you're
fighting to go all right hold on this
one let me get here
what the [ __ ] yeah that's the craziest
thing i could ever think of i think it
starts with the girl blasting the dude
though right
oh no [ __ ] no
okay all right maybe not no
at all i'm not saying that like
his fights didn't start with me hitting
him first
but
i don't remember i don't remember him
ever punching me
i don't but you allow it don't let me
let me i don't remember him ever like
straight on that's why she doesn't
remember no i do remember him like
because he
the thing with your dad is like
getting slapped hurts way more than
getting punched
slaps things for
hours
and hours i've been punched but
when your dad like would slap me i was
like just [ __ ] suck me because that
[ __ ] hurts man
it hurts a lot
and it's like her whole entire face not
just like like a thought knot you know
here let me just try it
[ __ ] it we've already come to this
establishment that you have a weak ass
punch so
you can't prove anything
with this
weak punch or glass jaw my dad had
one of the two because you hit me pretty
hard and went that wasn't [ __ ]
and it was a punch and knew nothing
i'm sorry no i'm not saying that
should i hit you harder i know i i wish
you would have so because that's just so
i knew like that's all you got you can't
i wanted to kill you
you can't talk to me no
stop you stop you
stop it right now
it hit me so [ __ ] off
you leaned into it
you're an [ __ ] i remember everything
uh next question thank you
ready no
ready marty
next question
why and where
when did you meet wendy
you said you weren't gonna make me cry
okay so when i was like 10 or 11 she's
like
she just appeared [ __ ] liar no i
swear to god she just appeared i was
walking and then the sun hit my eyes i
don't remember like actually meeting her
i just remember all of a sudden she was
just there
and that was it i don't remember her
memories like i remember i remember
actually meeting her
but i remember the time i met an
entity but i just remember her
i'm so glad these cameras are catching
the things i'm not crazy he's not i'm
not crazy
he's uh your contradictions in your
speech are [ __ ] crazy
somebody write down every time she
contradicted herself in the in the
comments why are you starting [ __ ]
you're just trying to start [ __ ] i love
you you just want me to get in arguments
with people
no one's gonna argue i am why now i
don't know
don't don't talk to the club this was a
nice story
yeah it wasn't it would have been
you started with don't make me cry no
they don't just talk about
i don't remember where and when i
when i did on my first birthday i
remember the sweetest voice
forrest gump was coming back again a lot
think this episode oh my god a lot go
go what continue where did you meet
wendy i just told you she appeared she
appeared and then she never went away
when at 11 yeah like 10 11 years where
did she live that you she lived okay so
we lived across the roof from the church
she lived across
the park next to the armory
which houses and those facing the armory
facing your house facing the park she
looked one street over so the the tears
up this is closer to the liquor store or
closer to the ve street closer to the v
street gotcha i know exactly
so she moved a couple blocks remember
where the library was at that one
library in the middle of all those um
low housing projects
she lived like across the street from
the um
yeah there was used to be a library in
there
yeah
i don't know a doll ever took me to the
library that was well no i wasn't gonna
well by then you when you were
of age or
of age
it was already gone but um
yeah she lived over there
you mean born
no when you're old enough to go to a
library it was already gone
okay
you can't have a [ __ ] library in the
middle of the projects i'm sorry it
feels like we're working on the library
where i'm searching it like where that
apartment she lived there with her aunt
and then she moved to el monte with her
mom what's up monty down here yeah
when i was like 14 15.
until she was about 18 after she had
ariel and then she moved back down to
the oh i didn't know that yeah i hated
it
i went up there one year to visit her
and her mom got kind of crazy
and
i had to
leave it was for like
hey uh put that might towards you i had
to leave because her mom was kind of on
one that sounds bomb yeah
okay you wanna hit this no okay so you
met wendy so you started hanging out at
18. she has a kid no we started hanging
out when when we i was about 12 30. i'm
saying back oh yeah yeah yeah and then
she had ariel while 18 and she moved
back to
merced
yeah and that's where
i met her
i mean my whole life i've known her
whole life yeah but
um
i'm trying to think of how old if you
guys are 18 you had me at 18. yeah she
was yeah she had ariel at 18. well i'm a
little bit older than ariel yeah so you
had me at 18 so
like 17 18. well i turned barely turned
18 when you were born yeah barely turned
18. yeah
okay yeah so
then she had ariel and then she still
lived in the those that area but just
those are gone now it's weird yeah i
know yeah but just like where the curve
is oh hold on wendy was my mom's best
friend yeah sorry let me put this
response oh yeah wendy was my best sorry
my mom was my mom's best friend ready
yeah okay so
the first time i ever saw weed
it was probably your house the coke
remember the coke stores yeah the coke
where i walk in and i saw some mexican
dude and his face full of coke and big
preston put his hand over my face and
walked me out the door yeah that was her
husband big preston married to wendy
yeah there we go
yeah that's the little perspective so
little preston pj
yesterday was at the event he was there
no some dude just like came up
like all hyped up whatever and he's like
yeah my cousin pj i might
what was the kid's name
no and then i realized like
from where you first out from parallel
oh you mean preston you mean
hannah's impressive and then he called
him and i was on facetime with preston
from the story i haven't seen him in a
couple years but he's got like a beard
does he really yeah you look like a
grown man well yeah you guys are all
grown up i know it was so weird to see
him like grown looking
um
[Music]
yeah so anyway there's a story i want
you to tell me that you said you came
home one day and you said grandpa was
high as [ __ ]
yeah one time my grandpa was high as
hell on weed yes i came home and
wendy was there me too i almost did this
wendy was there and my dad was there and
i was like i looked at both i knew she
was hot as [ __ ] because i could just
tell by looking at her and then
my dad was sitting there like this on
the chair
i was like what the [ __ ] man
that's all he did and i was like did you
get my dad high
she was like no i didn't get you like
yes you did don't lie she's like yeah we
smoked i was like she got my dead high
but i already knew he smoked
but you don't but not recreationally my
best
i thought you meant like i don't know
what to do with my hands right now right
i don't know what to do with my hands
no no no
but i mean i didn't expect that you know
it's like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
man i figured out my dad was getting
high as [ __ ] up in the attic one time
i i'm like a couple times like i think i
smell something i think my food smell
like weed
reminded me of my childhood yeah i used
to smell that when i was a kid then i
saw him come down with the bloodshot
eyes one time i'm like oh it's [ __ ]
over
and immediately just started literally
that's when i started smoking weed heavy
two weeks later i'm stealing his weed
that's what it always comes down to
and the thing is when i have kids one
day and they're that age they'll be able
to steal my weed for sure because i have
so much weed i would never i feel so bad
about it i really believe he barely had
any weed over there
you still haven't [ __ ] ate the shitty
weed at the time i'm over i was brutal
with it wait he knew i was doing it he
wouldn't say anything yeah he can't say
anything maybe your mom really smoked
and he was like she's still my weed
again i don't know and they didn't want
to say anything in my mind
we had a little my mind he knew
but i don't know he had to dunk on me
not his last but close to his last
he'd go out walk the dog i'm not going
to do
he knew i don't know i was a piece of
[ __ ] for that yeah i was a piece of [ __ ]
was hard to come by oh yeah especially
it's buffalo it's [ __ ] snow
yeah it's nothing but snow and poverty
and rick james
james
thank you yes i mean from what i hear
from your stories yeah like we're saying
nothing meth in poverty
how far away did like where did rick
james
like five minutes from where i'm like
from in buffalo basically yeah real
close
he was right downtown the infamous
little area buffalo called the perry
projects oh my god i love it yeah mm-hmm
but he was like the only like growing up
you know yeah there wasn't he was here
yeah yeah from
google dolls and rick james but then
dolls yeah
i don't know like maroon 5 and gucci
[Laughter]
it one time and i went i don't really
like it and pepper loved it i don't know
you didn't really like it that much okay
so i just put it out on my head then you
know who the google dolls are with james
rick james who played i know your face
well no you don't not right now
how about this i got a i got a
song from 2000
i don't know seven
that my producer made for me and we're
in the studio one of the singers from
the rick james band was friends with the
dude that on the city was in there i got
a son he wrote and sang me a hook
and
it's just waiting to have a song put to
it
me featuring you know digs from the rick
james band
so fun little fun fact
[ __ ] drop some [ __ ] music
this year you should probably work on
that yeah i'm thinking about it we're
getting around to it yes
i got some beats made by this guy named
o.g
[Laughter]
and it sounds like mexican americans but
just with different words because i
think you shouldn't plagiarized it
um
[Music]
all right cool so you met windy there
i was just wondering and then the
grandpa story
um
so i have another story and i want to
hear it in full detail gee
don't make me
drag me ahead of you
but
can you remember here's a story
can you remember the worst fight you
ever had with my dad
the worst one ever
there's so many times i know all right
well the worst one was it just a fact
like everybody knew like you guys fought
all the time like everybody it was just
a known thing i don't know i have no
idea the family and stuff i have no idea
i don't know
i don't know oh i was a little kid i
have no idea gotcha okay all right she
doesn't give a [ __ ] about [ __ ]
like i'm asking like with april it was
like a running joke that she beat dudes
up like every everybody knew about it
or oh yeah i don't know if anybody knew
that there was like
violence going on i mean i'm sure they
did you know i had like a broken nose at
one point and all that [ __ ] so a black
eye and all that good [ __ ]
but i don't know about like no one said
anything if they did and then
you know
yeah so the worst fight
we went over the one that thomas uh
refereed
last night remember
you i don't think you were born yet but
he like we were fighting and he where
on the house on is it maple
the one that he just moved out of the
little one yeah yeah that one
yeah
he broke my radio my stereo system
he broke all my albums
you know he didn't break my albums
we always hear about all the stuff
why i don't remember the reason why i
think that's a big question i don't
remember i'm sorry i know but my dad's a
very i'm in no way
am i saying oh that's cool
there's no there's no way my dad had any
right to do any of that
i want to know was there ever a time
that you were like oh he's going to
fight me if i say this [ __ ]
but there should never be that fear of
like oh i shouldn't say he's going to
hit me you should have been gone i get
it you stay with him but it's over who's
passed was there ever a time like that
you can remember of why you guys fought
because you told me one time why he
punched you in the mouth and i went
that was so mean mom why would you say
that to him also why did he hate you and
you just stayed i never thought of that
i seeing you guys always made me think
of girls are suck [ __ ] stupid is she
still like we could just leave that's
what i always saw i saw other people
dealing with him like why are you
staying okay so i would leave and then
go to my mom because i was very very
young i don't know i get that and then
she would make sure she would drive me
so [ __ ] crazy that i would rather get
my ass back i can't hold on let's not go
to grandma let's not get there why not i
have another question about grandma
ready go
what's the worst fight also can you ever
remember reeves
[Music]
[ __ ] you and he was like what the [ __ ]
you yeah there's gotta be one time or
you're lying to yourself because you
know there is there has to be
there has to be one of the worst times
in your life and you know sometimes you
don't remember but earlier like my
memory is [ __ ] bomb
[ __ ] look at marty's smile he goes
damn he's got you there i know everybody
remembers every little everything
remembers everything i've ever done to
piss her off there's gotta be one thing
a girl called the house i was like what
the [ __ ] he showed up to sharing being
born with a hickey on his neck and you
were pissed of course i was mad i know
something there's got to be a time well
i think all that like should be one
thing where you're like well the thing
is like okay so
when he would do all that like mess
around and do all that [ __ ] it was like
it stayed with me so it was like
anything he did was just like
resent it anymore i resented him yeah
and i was stuck
because i went home my mother would
drive me [ __ ] batshit crazy
and then if i went with him
we would just fight
but the fighting was easier because he
was gone a lot
so that's why i stayed longer than i
should have because he was the truck
driver he was always gone goddamn that
makes sense yeah that's why i stayed
there but then when he would come home
he was just a [ __ ] dumbass
you know there's a time you're sitting
there standing there 18 years old and
you guys are his house and you're like
why did this fight start
i don't remember the fight why this
fight started were you being a dick was
he being a dick probably both together
yes there's gotta be a time you're like
he hates when i call him stu don't call
him stupid
my dad hates being called stupid and he
hates when people say it and she calls
him stupid as a first name
so it was ever that you guys just
started fighting i don't remember
calling him stupid but whatever but
that's been so long ago i mean i don't
remember [ __ ] i don't remember that i
tried to block that out as soon as it
was over that's all that's fine then you
have to answer the question because you
don't remember it i don't remember
that's what i'm asking like there's got
to be a time i just remember fighting
yeah that's what i'm asking like this is
there's got to be a time you're like
yeah one time i said some [ __ ] to
him and he punched me right in the mouth
or one time he said something to me and
he'll talk to some girl and i punched
him in the back of the head
that's what i was asking is there ever a
reason because i never asked like but
why were you fighting i've never asked
that i don't remember the reason how odd
is that i've never asked why
i don't know that's fine that's an
answer okay that's perfect that's fine
you can say i don't know i don't know
sometimes i don't know either
but for you to go i don't remember it's
[ __ ] oh i i don't know i don't
remember well i don't know
that's fine but i remember it means i
don't want to talk about this no i don't
remember
next question
so do you remember the worst fight you
ever got with my dad i tried to tell you
but you wouldn't shut up well the next
question you could just put so back to
the question so back to the question
thomas
i got to find something we were fighting
and then he was like breaking all my
[ __ ]
and like you're right i did [ __ ] up and
ask you something else you were telling
the story yeah breaking all my [ __ ] and
then he took my albums my vinyl and
would like took a butter knife just down
one side
damn so he ruined all my albums what
were you doing while he's doing this i
wasn't home i came home to that why was
he mad about it he was an idiot i knew
because he knew that would bother me
that would hurt me
there's got to be a reason i don't
remember the reason that's crazy to me
sorry i know i just remember like that's
crazy my dad is not a piece of [ __ ]
where he's like you know what i'm going
to do today i want to have to be [ __ ]
working and on drugs
something has to happen there's going to
be a breaking point
i can remember one where you told me i'm
like but why did he hit you like he
punched me in the face and knocked me
out i go what why well i told him that
his mom's a [ __ ] immigrant and she's
[ __ ] stupid he can't speak english oh
he's right like she's [ __ ] stupid
you've been here 30 years but can't
speak say that either i remember what i
said
but it wasn't said it was i didn't say
it to like
yes
let me finish
do you want me to finish i want you to
finish but i like calling on you on your
board okay so i said it because
i and it wasn't true at all what i was
saying about her
but i said it because i knew it would
bother him
because he was an [ __ ] yeah he's
trying to get you to admit to pushing
his buttons into a no he was fighting so
i mean he's going to tell me some [ __ ]
well whatever i'm going to tell you some
[ __ ] that i know is going to piss you
off i'm not going to sit here and argue
all day with you over some dumb [ __ ] i'm
going to go right for your neck
and i would say some [ __ ] that pissed
him off and it always worked
there you go i'm so glad i'm so mature
at like three i'm so [ __ ] happy i
have to deal with any girl like you ever
in my life that would i would have oh
why is it okay so it can't just be no
because i would have been like that to
him i would have been a piece of [ __ ]
i've never had to deal with a bad person
like that that would and it worked but
oh why am i well because okay because
he's a piece of it hold on a lot of the
times the only thing i could get on him
was to say [ __ ] because he was way
stronger than me
so like after the fighting and i really
couldn't fight no more it was just me
running my mouth because i knew i'm okay
you may have whipped my ass but i'm
still gonna say i'm all up in your
[ __ ] head i'm still gonna say some
stupid [ __ ] to you while i'm laying here
doing this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah he's
around i'll shut the [ __ ] up but when
he's gone
i'm talking again yeah so it was kind of
like that situation so it's funny to me
but that's what i'm saying the only time
you've ever told me why you guys fought
was that you called him that you told
him that he was stupid and grandma can't
speak english no i would say i didn't
say that i said i'm just telling you
what you told me
you told me this one i was a kid i
probably did i don't know
once again i'm only going off what
you've said to me i'm not making things
up because that's why i ask questions if
i don't know the answer sure
it's called questions like an interview
every time you've only proved my points
true what that i don't remember a lot of
[ __ ] no that you could just be like i
don't remember that hey the truth is
but i'm just going based on what the
[ __ ] you told me okay so next question
next question
uh you never finished it you broke all
your [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah and that was
the worst fight and then we no we boxed
yeah and then like you came home you saw
all that [ __ ] well i came home
something i don't sharing was really
little it was thanksgiving this big i
was oh wait he came home that big he
came home and i was there and i was
gonna leave with my parents
and then we got into like this huge
[ __ ] fight he broke all my [ __ ] we
boxed whatever oh she had to be a
one-year-old then yeah she was little
and my mom still came over but saw that
i was all [ __ ] up
and so like
this is really [ __ ] up too
like i told her me and elmer just got in
a fight the whole house was wrecked and
she just kind of stepped over me grabbed
serene and left
left me there
like i'm sick of this [ __ ] no just like
i could give a [ __ ] oh that you just got
like brutally beaten up i'm taking
serene and going
she's just she didn't give a [ __ ] she
did not care i mean she did care no she
didn't about sharing oh yeah about
shireen
she did care not that her you know 16
year old daughter just got like
violently beaten up damn that was it
yeah
my dad wasn't allowed to do anything
yeah i get that that was my next
question yeah my dad wasn't allowed to
allowed like like she told to tell him
to just to stay out of it
yes because she was basically an adult
and didn't i was 16. no that's what i'm
saying when my grandma's thinking it was
like well she doesn't even [ __ ]
listen to me why the [ __ ] do i care i
give up i was like do what you're going
to do i don't give a [ __ ] you told me
you guys got no you guys didn't like
each other
so i get where my grandma's at but you
can't just like i mean i can't be like
hey don't stay on the ground [ __ ] you
i'm going to take the one that i have a
chance to [ __ ] make good i get what
she i get why she's like no i'm [ __ ]
no it wasn't also she was super super
[ __ ] the way she was saying they
didn't like each other yeah just said
that man yeah i'm saying it's your fault
it's not your fault at all i'm but what
i'm saying is she's looking at like you
guys are [ __ ] there's some other
things and fighting each other no there
was no drugs at that point
there was no drugs at that point you
said you stopped doing drugs in 1991 in
1987.
i'm just stating facts here
but that would mean she wasn't on drugs
though i wasn't on the streets
you started when you're 15.
i started smoking weed when i was 15.
you said the first time you did crystal
method pcp you were 14.
yeah i was on pcp but not meth
i re i don't i remember the first time i
did your sister was already born i
didn't like it because i did acid and
that's when i got pregnant
acid makes you pregnant
yeah
and then um
i had him
and then it was like a long time after
that what
nothing just soaking it in
yeah soaking in the math and the numbers
and how i'm completely right to continue
so hard
i know so
you're trying to justify your grandma's
frustrations no my grandma that was a
horrible thing she did yeah but you're
trying to what i'm saying i'm imagining
what she's thinking like i've had to
deal with this [ __ ] so much we
don't even like each other i i will take
this one out of the situation
that's i get it i get why
she shouldn't have done that she's she
shouldn't of course that's her daughter
what the [ __ ] she should have killed my
dad that's crazy i would have killed him
she told me she would have me arrested
before she would have your dad arrested
yeah they were on the i don't like you
thing yeah i get it i understand yeah
but also
they don't like each other
i mean that kind of says a lot you don't
like your kid and you don't like your
mom you guys are feuding
i mean i don't expect anything less from
her
from being a dick that's like being
horrible
but i get why she went no no no
you guys are fighting give me this
[ __ ] baby
i get that at least they shouldn't go oh
they want this [ __ ] by yourself no she
went i'm gonna take this [ __ ] baby
out of here and let me know what's going
on later
i get what she's thinking i'm not saying
it was right i was [ __ ] up but i'm
saying
that's what i'm imagining she thought
because that's what i and on top of that
she was like had some malice
that's that's what i'm saying like
she would have done it if that part
wasn't there she would like yo both of
you let's get the [ __ ] out she's like no
deal with the [ __ ] you're no this is
your boyfriend this is your life you
want to have a baby in here
he wasn't even there at that point he
had left already yeah
it was just me
there with the yeah no i i get it i
understand it's not like she was right
i'm saying
i understand i'm trying to think of why
she would do that it's the only logical
explanation
right okay
do you agree no
okay
that's fair no i don't agree with that
at all because i fought with your sister
but it let someone touch my daughter i'm
going to kill you i didn't say that yeah
i said she should be fighting with her
like like it was kong versus godzilla
and anyone touches her um that's not
what we're saying once again no you're
thinking of something else no i'm not
she's saying that if shireen i said that
too i said i would have killed my dad i
would have not left my daughter on the
ground i'm not saying that and once
again we're getting into one of these
arguments where you're like
even though yeah
do you think that's what she was
thinking i don't care what she was
thinking
then just say that and i'll get on to
the next thing
there's no excuse for that i didn't say
hey come up with an excuse for grandma
i'm saying do you think that's probably
what happened she doesn't like you you
don't like her and she's like i'm gonna
take the baby out of here [ __ ] you
probably that sounds like that sounds
like exactly what happened
and you can agree and say that but you
don't have to be like no there's a long
history of why she didn't do that
because one time that's not what i'm
saying you guys don't like each other
she took the baby because she was like
yo you deal with whatever you're dealing
with [ __ ] this
that has to be or else you would have
left that but that wasn't like an
isolated incident it's not then that's
nice but her point is it's never okay to
do that to her that's what i said too
like you shouldn't have done that you
should have took her ass what the [ __ ]
you doing leaving her there are you okay
would have been a good guy you know yeah
yeah i get that it's not the first time
you guys are [ __ ] beating the show
that's i think that's the first time
she's ever saw that oh i get that but
yeah there's been times where you come
back like we're [ __ ] fighting and all
this crazy [ __ ] he hit me and she's like
well deal with it if that you're gonna
stay with this [ __ ] that's how
my grandma was like i have two other
ones
you're a dick to me i'm a dick to you
deal with that's not my grandma's like
being petty i think it's her like
revenge of like i'm not helping you yeah
you don't even [ __ ] like me that's
that way she's thinking she's petty as
[ __ ]
i'm not wrong i mean that's probably
what she thought
yeah yeah
simple simple
not isolated i understand that
and i'm only talking about one
thing
and everything else you're allowed to
hold over her head for a series i don't
give a [ __ ] that generation of your
grandmother kind of treated their kids
like [ __ ] more it was more normal to
like yes not be a like great parent or
like you were just you were on a level
above your kid in that era right i think
so like it wasn't kid first type of
thing yeah she's like i have three yeah
kids i got a job your dad's got a job
stop kids feelings
like important to society no not at all
not even a little bit
like those you can get beat up at school
by your teacher still yeah your hair was
like yeah no [ __ ] her up huh
she was yeah and you did
so i get it i understand
but that's what i'm trying to understand
is
that was the worst fight
after all of that okay that was the
worst thing must have been bad
yeah it was pretty bad
yeah but
you guys have been in that situation
like 50 times right okay no i'm asking
over the course of you moved out at 16
17 you always go to grandma's house and
live at grandma grace's house
is that where you guys were living is
what i'm asking no we're living in a
house on maple at 16. yeah oh what the
[ __ ] they let you live leave yeah
what were they gonna i mean they didn't
give a [ __ ] what i did oh see this time
period is so odd to me because it's like
you're in school but you don't live at
grandma's but dad doesn't live at
grandma grace actually i was when we
lived in the house i was still going to
school
as of high school yeah
17.
okay
that's what was confusing like grandma
walked didn't wear to grandma grace's it
was like a house on maple i said that in
the beginning okay so if it's all you
did with the [ __ ] records see i'm
trying to put it into my perspective of
you guys were moved out i didn't know
you moved out that young
i thought you guys lived at grandma
grace's until you guys were 18 for some
reason
we did it was a mess everything was a
mess around that time
hmm
i feel like we're getting somewhere
yeah that's what i'm trying to
understand like what time period is it
um
okay
i have to pee again again
this is what happens you don't smoke
weed what happens he's gotta pee
he's gotta pee
i'll be right back leave the camera
running yeah hit the camera i'm so sorry
but no you're fine i drink too much beer
and coffee full of lies
full eyes of miller light
this is why you don't drink mother lies
i love
it oh my legs hurt
remember that one time
remember that one time my mom had to go
to the bathroom
but you remember that one time where i'm
so happy i'm a logical person yeah i'm
not crazy uh-huh i'm only saying the
things that she stated to me yeah
and the logical situation of my
grandma's thing and i go without you
dragging everything else in
any time i have a talk arguing with my
mom it i have to do this hold on i do
this as a phrase i go
pretend that you don't have nine years
of [ __ ] you want to talk
let's talk about one justice thing one
thing
let me get to the end
but you know back then i'm like oh [ __ ]
you almost it's like getting a bunch of
puppies into a pen and one keeps
escaping you're like yo i almost had it
this time oh oh we're getting bad and
then it all unfolds you have to start
again
conversation with my mom
ready nope we are back today we are back
with the uh birth father of the child
from kindergarten cop
you get your own damn family
what are you talking about
when you had your hair slipped back you
kind of like the dad that tries to find
the sun kindergarten cop deep [ __ ]
reference that's sorry sharing came to
christmas one time dressed like that
away
my hair is out of control
it's okay susie it's fine
ready yeah
and we're back
with geriatric bathroom breaks
that's what this segment's called
okay
what are you gonna do
i feel better though now because now i'm
not like oh god i gotta be here
you know oh so you were lying because of
the bathroom thing i just can't you know
when you try to i was trying like can we
just cause i have to go to the bathroom
yeah you say just hey i got a pizza
please and a coffee and some water i
shouldn't drink accomplishment at your
age it's i can to all those liquids all
those liquids
and no food yet
want some cubbies no okay
on to my next one
you know what's so crazy being able to
talk mad [ __ ] and not get [ __ ] not do
this
which i never talked [ __ ] when i was a
kid because
of the fear
but here we go continue ready go i'm
like this next j
you ready
you sure
this next one gets [ __ ] crazy as hell
you might fall
am i to flip the table on you she can't
if you could flip the table on me mom i
would not i would still be afraid of you
so
we need a new table so we do need to
have why what's wrong if you chop this
[ __ ] in half it's okay what's
wrong with this table
um i'll give you guys you said some
crazy racist [ __ ] to me the other day
i was sitting in here and like oh it was
very
not progressive
let's just say that it's not progressive
right is it like a white oak table it is
a white oak table whoa
whoa
with a brown lacquer with brown that's
why it's mad white oak aka awoke table
[Laughter]
oh my god it's [ __ ] boring yeah he
got mad at my offensive jokes
i don't even tell jokes i'm just talking
i gotta be honest
you ready
yeah on to the next topic
where oh [ __ ] do you think
disney
where do you think you would be
right now if you never broke up with my
dad
legitimately like stayed with him this
whole time yes oh i don't know
getting probably looking like mickey
morick from all the plaques of surgery
trying to get this fixed in that [ __ ]
shade yeah cause you know how he beat up
his face
yeah yeah i'd probably need extensive
plastic surgery you're saying my dad
could be a plastic surgeon no i was
saying for fighting i am kidding i would
probably need all that because like
my nose is still kind of messed up
and
like it bothers me sometimes and it's
been how long
like five six months
so when you guys are fighting like how
how long are you you keep saying boxing
like when you say boxing it makes me
think of like
you guys are like moving around and well
like
because like guys he
like i said he was way bigger than me
yeah that's and i was way smaller then
and it was more like
we would
like slap slap slap and then like he
would do the whatever and then that was
pretty much the end of it where's the
whatever what's that finishing like he
would like slap me so hard and i would
just be done well i was expecting
backbreakers
like one time he tackled me i wasn't
like i was walking and i turned around
right when i turned around he like
tackled me and knocked me out and that
[ __ ] hurt
so bad i don't ever you weren't you
aren't boring i can't wrap my head
around somebody going like yeah my
girlfriend make i'm gonna tackle he
tackled me and that's that's [ __ ]
preposterous to me so bad because when
you get when you fall you like fall but
your head smacks
and he knocked me out and i woke up to
him going oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that hurt that that hurt really bad that
hurt real bad and another time he threw
me out of the truck
the diesel
ow oh yeah that should hurt too [ __ ]
yeah were you driving no he was driving
i don't know
we were moving yeah
yeah the [ __ ] dude how did you do that
you know how did he do it i don't
remember oh oh i know exactly we're
right there by am pm if i had to keep
somebody out of a truck i know exactly
how to do it how do you get the door
reaching i think i was trying to get out
already he just kicked your ass and he
pushed me yeah because i was like i'm
not not doing this with you and i left
and pmv oh so he wasn't going fast yet
he's probably going like twenty fifteen
twenty a girl i grew up with her mom
died from that exact scenario really
yeah jumping out of a diesel no like out
of a car yeah oh yeah now i had to do
that once i had to jump out of a moving
car with him
that [ __ ] was like you know you see
people jump out of a moving car and they
roll and like get up no no no it's not
no of course not no it's none of that
you [ __ ] and then like oh [ __ ] and then
roll your road rash oh god it sucks so
bad that hurt bad
how long were you guys together seven
years eight years
eight long wonderful
long years
it's such a trip thank you actually it
wasn't like it's weird it was it was
like i never really had like the
opportunity or the balls to just be like
you know [ __ ] this i'm done you know it
was always like some situation some
situation some situation kids are
involved but it sounds like you two
brought that out of each other like is
he was he like that in the next
relationship he went on into
never again um well i heard different
but that's fine you are different from
what
from never again
amber
that girl jessica
you to this one white girl and then it's
just been his wife
well i'm talking about oh yeah yeah well
my dad was drinking him and my and my
stepmom got into a like three fights in
one week
i do remember that because i remember
like wait what my dad pushed duress
is this coming back again damn but it
was when my dad was doing the blackout
drinking fifth [ __ ]
for a while in order my dad got weird
remember that time you called me asked
me you were in working like have you
seen my dad i was like why would i see
your dad because he's missing like what
the [ __ ] what do you mean he's missing
all the time i think it was shireen that
called me and asked me if i seen her dad
and they were putting up flyers because
he was missing but he was in california
yeah that would getting high
[ __ ] disappear for five six days yeah
yeah so she thought he was dead out of
nowhere like missing dead and he's in
california getting loaded [ __ ] yeah yeah
but no like besides well then again
doing drugs being around the wrong
person uh-huh drinking being around the
wrong person
my dad's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know what i mean like happens to
just be sober and he's the nicest
funniest [ __ ] and he's chilling
when he gets drunk he's not violent as
[ __ ] it's not like my dad's like oh he's
drinking watch out
when i heard like he pushed like what
like when's the last time i heard my dad
hitting somebody was with my mom so i
like wait wait there's no way bro it's
been like 15 years there's no way and
then i found out why i'm like
yeah he's wrong i mean no matter what
you put you're tripping you can't do
that
but i'm like oh okay so it's not like he
got drunk and just [ __ ] went off well
hey you know [ __ ] you it's like oh you
guys were in a fight
doesn't justify it
ever but i'm like okay so it's not like
my dad gets drunk and just hits people
like okay something happy because my dad
was an alcoholic drink every day he
wasn't punching people every day or
[ __ ] throwing people were you go you
know are you drinking with him
no my dad didn't drink until i was like
16. gotcha yeah i started like 16 my dad
started drinking all right
with him with her it was just drugs it
was just weed he didn't he started
drinking when he was like he was on
drugs with you he was doing [ __ ]
crank well i i did it for a little bit
but he kept doing yeah that's what i'm
saying like the drugs he was always
crying and i was like this is this
stuff's crap it's not it's not fun it
wasn't fun
it just got to work like this is i'm not
doing this somewhere this is gross i'm
not doing it and i would just smoke weed
yeah
yeah but my dad got sober when i was
like 16
and then
stopped doing crank and then started
drinking heavy when i turned like 18 to
cope with the [ __ ]
and that's when that [ __ ] happened so
that's why i was asking like so what
happened what situation you just pushed
her i know they were fighting and he was
drunk oh
okay
there's hope
yeah i'm like is my dad just a straight
piece i mean yes that's a piece of [ __ ]
move you can't come back from that
but it's more like can i trust you
around [ __ ] like oh okay you
didn't just drink a bottle no you okay
okay
your dad was probably one of the
funniest people i ever knew yeah his dad
is hilarious completely no filter he has
no filter and it's like i've heard yeah
yeah but he is a very funny guy
and he's very likable super
that's what i'm saying thomas was
worried to have him on because of that
yes yeah you might have to like bleep
him a lot but it's gonna be i mean if
you have people that are not sissies
then it's gonna be great oh again
dude i can't even tell the story he told
me this if you can't if you can't if you
have too many people that oh well that
offends me or that offends me or that
you know what just go be [ __ ]
offended and shut up yeah nobody needs
to know you were offended who gives a
[ __ ] yeah and there's always something
but if you could take that it's a joke
and not get your
you know your vagina all hurt and
puckered up then you'll be fine
people are just too sensitive now and i
can't i hate and i'm a very offensive i
know i want to hear this [ __ ] i would
love that oh the [ __ ] that i want to say
and the stuff that i do say are like
very vastly different things
the the joke the jokes i have you
[ __ ] i have to wait i'm holding
a mic on stage for it to be okay
you can't even do that now i mean i'll
do it i'll go i don't [ __ ] yeah you
can't cancel somebody that doesn't give
a [ __ ] that's true you cannot i don't
give a [ __ ] if something i said wasn't
truly [ __ ] if i say go oh [ __ ] i
shouldn't you could only get cancelled
if you let yourself get canceled that's
how i see it you know other than that if
you don't give a [ __ ] then you can't get
canceled if you don't give a [ __ ]
because it was nothing yeah you win but
if you don't give a [ __ ] like
some other comedian crate doing crazy
[ __ ] and you're just still famous won't
say anything
then it's like oh
but people are just so interested
yeah they're in a hurry to get offended
and be all upset
then go go watch something else then
yeah
you know it's like just let the people
that are not you know offended have
their fun
there's more people that are like not
karen's than there is people that are
yeah that's true you know i don't give a
damn just don't bother me i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah
but back to what i was saying sure it
was weird knowing that my dad used to be
the [ __ ] out of my mom and i'm just
sitting here chilling hanging out
playing football
it was odd yeah you know
it was especially getting older like
my dad is so awesome it's so weird
knowing you were such a piece of [ __ ]
and then i talked to him one time about
it i was like 25 like you guys are just
fighting each other goes thomas
i'm a piece of [ __ ] i should have done
that i was [ __ ] up i was on drugs and
even when i was on drugs
your mom is just so mean
he's saying it's not her fault
i should never hit her she's a [ __ ]
my girlfriend like i should never have
hit her
but
what the [ __ ] he would say like there's
only so many [ __ ] times i could say
and just take it and i was like dad
she's mean but you can't just hate her
because i know i'm dumb and i was a kid
and i'm [ __ ] dumb i wish i could take
it back he always says like what's your
ticket back
but
[ __ ] that's all you always just
say but watch you remember when he
remember when he called to apologize to
me yeah he called like years later wants
to call my dad my dad wants you to call
him i was like am i in trouble what the
[ __ ] why wait this was like five years
ago grandpa was still alive no grandpa
oh dead yeah
and i was like i don't need i don't know
whatever and so i get on the phone and
he's like i just want to apologize i'm
like i don't need your
we're kids dude i'm not holding nothing
against is that like a i think it was a
12-step thing but he didn't say that he
was uh sober by then yeah but he was
probably still doing the step thing you
know maybe wrong all you're right or
write all your wrongs or whatever
and then um i was like i don't
i'm not holding anything against you
dude we were both kids you it's not like
you just hit me i hit you too you know
tried to kill you three times man it's
like
we were both wrong
but i was like well thank you i think
you know yeah it's nice what he did say
he's like now that i have like you know
now i have my other my younger daughters
i couldn't imagine someone doing that to
her to them and i was like
because he was not drugs though he was a
drug sharing his whole life right right
and sharing is not a girly girl right
but the thing that's what he did say to
me
someone doing that to my daughters and
me not doing nothing about it
and i was like okay i thank you mm-hmm
appreciate it
it's just good to get that off your
chest yeah i guess i mean i think he
just i don't know i don't it's just kind
of odd though because when i look at my
dad and i don't even think about that
[ __ ] i just go
it's goofy yeah he's funny he is funny
that's all i see so when it's like i
know people are like
you're over you're making fun of your
mom get him
cause it's [ __ ] funny
uh sorry it's funny when she bunched me
in the mouth yeah it was it wasn't funny
now thinking about it so long and
everything's it's like
carer
yeah we were young and we were kids and
then like if i had to do it now i'd be
like yeah [ __ ] this the situation's
terrible right i would have shot my dad
and
walking to the
i would have killed him
death
i would have stabbed him to death like
you did what oh you got to die now
it's a whole it's different
but i'm glad my grandma didn't do
nothing because my dad turned into a
very good person yeah but
it's just like damn dude that's a trip
knowing that somebody that's so [ __ ]
awesome could be such a piece of [ __ ] on
drugs you have to okay
it wasn't just drugs okay you have two
people me and your dad that really had
no direction
really didn't have parental
advice
no no no affection your grandma did try
to hug them a little bit but it was like
okay
for my grandpa to beat the [ __ ] out of
my grandma in front of everyone in front
of them yeah so that's where my dad's
like well she talked back i should beat
the [ __ ] out of her right i i'm not
blaming all that but my dad was brought
up and like he was brought up like that
just like my grandpa would [ __ ] my
grandma up like i'm the kid see that
[ __ ]
my grandpa would beat their ass every
week and a half they didn't do anything
as like a reminder of like i got you
guys on wow yeah but when you don't you
okay you have parents that like his
grandparents on his dad's side had no
education whatsoever my parents on my
side had very limited education
so you're already there's two
disadvantages right there and then you
bring a bunch of kids into this and you
really never progress
beyond 17 years old mentally
one has a severe mental you know issue
my mom and my dad always work
so i was just like whatever you know and
so on his dad's side it was always
that fear of violence that
at any time you never knew what was
going to set this man off
you know and so
you had
all these kids trying to raise
themselves
and in that point there was no internet
there was no you know there was dr spock
who gives a [ __ ] about that half the
time they thought it was the one from
star trek you know
it was just
then there's a lot to be said there
because back then you only knew what was
directly in front of you whereas now you
have a little periscope out to see the
rest of the world and what's normal
what's not normal right but back then
you you were just and then like yeah
right and then even on tv it was still
all like you know
it was oh you can't put that until
that's too that's too real for
television
and it wasn't until like what the 90s
and stuff like that when like beverly
hills 902 that came on and they had teen
pregnancy and drug use and all that [ __ ]
and that's when your generation started
seeing like the real world
we were still looking at you know
cartoons and dumb [ __ ] nothing made it
was all make-believe still mm-hmm so
real problems
weren't on television we didn't have the
internet we didn't have you know none of
us we just
lived yeah you know so that's why a lot
of kids my age growing up were on drugs
doing smoking weed smoking pcp then you
know that's when all that
trickle down [ __ ] started so what's
she saying is cartoons causes you to
have kids no it's just lack of education
i believe really like a strong lack of
education well i mean i just looking in
on it yeah
like oh i get why there was times when
i'm like you don't ever do this because
this is wrong
to him
no me telling you the first time my dad
hit you i'm not talking about that i'm
not talking about that i'm talking about
you had a different upbringing because
when when stuff would happen to me i
would sit you and your sister down this
is not normal
no you don't ever hit girls you do not
go and join gangs you do not lie you do
not steal you don't do that but when you
know when you have parents that don't
teach you none of that i appreciate you
you have just wild ass kids i appreciate
that you did that but marty did you hear
the way she worded that i would always
sit you guys down and teach you
i love it i did it's a different way you
did it
you were grabbing by my phone mine was
more out of fear pushing against the
wall yeah that was like what in the hell
i'm doing all this to keep you away from
this [ __ ] and now
it's coming up to you on the [ __ ]
playground what kind of nonsense i love
it no you did you're not lying i just
love the way you worded it and i love
the way i wear it because it's true it's
funnier
for you to say
i would sit you down and teach you guys
okay i would sit you down you grabbed me
by my shirt that was the game
that was the game
you ever [ __ ] joined a kid yeah i'm
looking up at sex well yeah because that
just scared me
i know
just thinking about your version versus
mine is so great because it's
it's what you said and that's what you
think okay but i love it i felt like you
needed a gang at that moment like yo i'm
gonna join just to have him beat this
girl's ass my mom's [ __ ] crazy what
did you what would you call it what was
the gang you called nor tent what
that's how i felt like i needed a crew
i needed a crew of long socks
[ __ ] to help me fight my mom
um
so yeah we blame cartoons for everything
in the world basically yeah bugs bunny
created the crips
okay
he did i can i really think it's blood's
bunny
shut the [ __ ] up
god marty oh that was so awesome
now i'm over here trying to think of
other people
no don't worry i can't i keep playing
yosemite sam over in my head and go
there's there's no gang i can no
oh [ __ ] um
okay so
to wrap that up
it's weird when i was growing up looking
at my dad going damn he's doing [ __ ]
that's crazy i never thought about him
bad and you just say yeah your dad's the
greatest huh when we want to hang out
with my dad it's just because we never
got to see when you were mean of course
you want to go hang out with my dad
no i'm just telling you why we are
always like that going why do you always
say so much [ __ ] about him
he's cool but yeah to you like that's
what matters mom
as a kid that's why i didn't understand
why i now get like used to beat the [ __ ]
out of it because he was doing other
stuff so i really didn't want you guys
to again he was doing stupid [ __ ] doing
drugs he's taking us around stu i i've
been the same do you remember the night
that the heroin addict brought you home
no oh yeah oh girl uh-huh that was his
girlfriend yeah but she was also emily
i'm on heroin but i'm bringing your kids
home i was like what amber no her um oh
oh i know you know i won't say her name
yeah i know you're talking about the
mexican girl yeah what's her name's
sister right what's his name little
sister i don't know
i saw her like 10 years later she was
all messed up but she was so cool yeah
she was cool oh man yeah she's like oh
thomas she ran i'm like oh no you're on
drugs yes
because you were with your dad you and
your sister with your dad and like two
o'clock in the morning she called me
like i'm bringing these kids home and i
was like okay
and she brought you guys home and i was
like what's going on dude and she's like
look i'm a junkie and i know what's
going on at that house that apartment
your kids should not be there and i was
like i really appreciate that thank you
yeah she was cool as [ __ ] yeah
um
yeah my dad didn't have a lot of
girlfriends
like ones that he brought around ever i
met two
what was that one girl's name though i
don't want to say it because she's i
think she still lives said she don't
want to [ __ ] put her on blast yeah i
remember her sharing loved her ass yeah
she was cool so when they broke up i
told her if whenever you want to come
see them
come see them because just because she
was a young chick in the comments she
didn't but i gave her the option because
it's like you guys are really close to
my you know she's she was she was cool
they liked you you liked her yeah so i'm
like yeah come see him whenever you want
to see him
i remember her name now i won't say it
yeah yeah but um
that was it that was pretty much the end
of it but thinking about like damn
that's what you should do that crazy
[ __ ]
and now looking at him now it's like
what the [ __ ] it's just weird yeah he
finally grew [ __ ] up and it's weird
because when i was like four i could
stand there and think just like now i'm
going
you were immature it's okay though well
he was a very young person i'm saying as
a kid i had to grow up so [ __ ] quick
because who the [ __ ] was gonna teach me
[ __ ]
you know like it wasn't like that
over there especially with my dad like i
was always cold into his ass i i always
remember like checking it like i'm five
i shouldn't be checking you mm-hmm
you're drunk i'm not getting in the car
i'll wait go to the store i'll wait him
uncle jaime was like get in the car you
guys are both drinking
oh wait you don't go how you want you're
a smart kid man
you know we're just [ __ ] smart and
they just got in the car just shit-faced
and drove to the store off 22nd street
last time
or second last time you said that name
again [ __ ] got it
he said it again
please bleep that name out peter thank
you peter
i told you see that name's too hard to
to remember no it's because i'm talking
a conversation i never have to blank his
name out in conversation with us we
could just call him blank from now on
uh-huh i know but we'll call him peter
no we'll call him please bleep that out
thank you very much blink um so to
finalize that
my dad finally grew up
you stayed there for like five to seven
years
that was over he called later said sorry
and i said where do you think you would
be if you stayed there
boom
i don't know dude because i think it
would have been horrible for like 10
years terrible and then i think he would
have grew the [ __ ] up a little sooner
yeah because he grew up at like 35 40.
not like 40. oh yeah 40 40. i know i'm
saying
i think he would have cleaned up around
like 32. yeah after i was all beat up
looking like i'm saying i think it would
have been bad for a while
just like it was i'm just saying if
that's what happened and i think you
guys would have been like you guys used
to beat the [ __ ] out of each other like
yeah
and emily they're [ __ ] they're great
couples
those are the ones at the mall those are
the people at the mall used to fight you
remember them big hair them
that's what would have happened i think
probably just being odd
there was too much done oh for sure i
was just like in some other universe
what would be happening like some marty
mcfly [ __ ]
what would be cause he got worse after
me
i know
yeah like real real bad after i left oh
yeah
yeah oh yeah he did always worked
never not showed up for work ever in
life
i will say that
um
you ready next one
sure next question
was that from i don't know okay i
thought that was a quote
after
[ __ ] finding out what your ex-husband
peter
did to your boyfriend
how did you stay with this man
after knowing what he was doing willing
to do and did
we talk about
what do you mean what are you talking
about i overheard what the [ __ ] he did
and i know what he did
okay we're going to talk about that off
counter because i don't know what you're
talking about
well we'll never know who he is
actually you know what can you bleep out
the name i just said uh-huh when i said
when he did so-and-so to that name let's
just bleep that out and give her some
weird
legal things let's bleep that name all
right
my mom was dating this guy
didn't really like him that much
he was like he was annoying he was
annoying okay right oh fast version my
mom was dating this guy didn't really
like him that much i remember i told you
the day peter came over for the first
time yeah that's when i met him and she
met him because it was her current
boyfriend's [ __ ] cousin and she's
like yo i'm not i'm not i don't look
good in this story no you don't yeah you
can't look good
she [ __ ] met her husband she was like
yeah i'm gonna marry this [ __ ]
[ __ ] this guy yeah the guy she was with
was the tallest [ __ ] in the
world
weiner he was a wiener
i didn't like him but he did teach me
how to wash knives when i was doing
dishes
so i would give him that and sweeping
but he actually said don't be [ __ ]
dumb you're sweeping it all in one
circle just sweep into one file and then
get to the next part i went you're right
chill out also [ __ ]
and uh but my girl are you telling me
how to [ __ ] watch it you know how i
got him
got him to leave
hold on
i'm getting to that i don't just get to
it then
this is why i have to bleed the name out
anyway peter comes over teaches me hacky
sack and i'm like yo this guy was like
axel rose he has no shirt with overalls
nothing to do he's got nothing to do for
sure
because you don't do that if you got
[ __ ] to do
long ass hair teach me hacky sacking you
over the rainbow i'm like yo
where did he learn this little do i know
it's
like california state penitentiary is
where he learned that the cdc
okay so um
current boyfriend let's just call him
current boyfriend guy you break up with
his ass and then i start seeing
okay
can you bleep it and possibly blur my
[ __ ] words
bleep it but keep that yeah all that
that was great and then i start seeing
peter come around [ __ ]
i'll tell you natalie peter's now blank
blank's way better like his weight's way
better and current boyfriend's way
better
boyfriend it gets yes
weiner weiner boyfriend boyfriend weiner
yeah
you break up with him and i started
seeing peter come around blank
[ __ ] i see him now i remember i started
seeing blake come around and i'm like
i like him
now or what the [ __ ] no then he went
away for a while no i'm not getting on
i'm talking about what made current
boyfriend leave you alone because he
didn't leave you alone because blank
made him leave me alone and why and what
hold on and what did he do to make his
own blood cousin leave him alone he told
him he was going to deal with him if he
came around me again no no no no no no
i'm not going to say well
because i remember what he said what was
hilarious situation was he in
when he said the words to him we were me
and blake were in the car and dumbass
pulled in behind us in front of my house
pulled in behind us in some truck
gets out didn't see blank in the car
gets out comes to my cuz i was driving
he comes to my window and starts
screaming at me
and i'm like
and blank was saying just let him talk
just let him talk and i was like i'm
gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna i'm gonna punch
this guy in the face he's like no no no
just let him talk
saying all kinds of crazy [ __ ] to me
um all kinds of [ __ ] and all this and
that and blah blah blah and i'm like
just justified keep going
you're with now with his cousin that he
no
no
no you have to say at least like maybe i
am wrong you started a story off with
that no it was like because when i broke
up with him i was already like i've had
it with you you need to go but he
shouldn't college that but he might all
right
i can see why you're mad but but he
didn't know about blank yet
oh oh he was just being addicted yeah he
was just being a piece of [ __ ] oh so he
was coming really got upset okay so he
must be right
i'm sitting there looking because he's
6'4 and i'm in the car and i'm looking
up and he's like
doing all this [ __ ]
so finally blank opens the door and
stands up and he's like let me [ __ ]
talk to you and look on dumbass's face
was just like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] because
remember i find out the kind of person
he is later his cousin knows exactly
yeah exactly who he is and all i heard
was no no no no no
but you don't know she's this he's like
i don't give a [ __ ] don't come around
here anymore she's with me now
he didn't leave you alone yeah he did
after that day i never saw him again
yeah yeah okay my mom's memory no no
after that day i never saw that fool
again [ __ ] but
what i did hear was here what do you
know for a fact because i know why no
what i heard when him and blank were
talking
i heard what he told him if you come
over here again this is certain things
are gonna happen to you
and that's when he left and never came
back okay
i mean my mom's leaving a big big big
big portion probably okay but it's
probably good that i do big portion out
we're leaving names out it's fine
i heard blank talking to
stupid [ __ ] his friend with a beard you
know who we're talking about bald yeah
guy yeah his best friend yeah i heard
him talking to him and you were there so
don't try to she's only going to try to
act like a biker's wife like i heard
nothing there's nine in my purse i don't
know how it got there listen i heard
once i don't remember so what did he say
no when we were in the car situation i
heard that part the thing after i did
what he told
what did what did blank say to current
boyfriend what
i'm not gonna say it i'm gonna say it
marty take a c for this one
she's you could just say i don't want to
say i don't want to say it i'll say it
she's over here acting so i wanna after
what i'm about to say and let everybody
in on after i tell them what happened
how did you go
i know most girls would have [ __ ] got
out of the relationship with their
boyfriend
what can i say it turned me on but what
i got to say it kind of turned me on
i am not karen she's caring for [ __ ]
good fellas most girls would have got
out of that relationship you shouldn't
have heard that then he put his hands he
should have had that moment so what
happened
was current boyfriend did not leave my
mom alone
i heard the whole thing that he
this made me scared but i was like also
like okay maybe that's what adults do
maybe that's the [ __ ] that happens
so apparently blank
dragged your [ __ ] current
boyfriend into that field
go ahead finish
he tied this fool to a chair
and poured gas on and was like i'm gonna
light you on fire [ __ ] you're
not leaving her ass alone i gave you the
[ __ ] opportunity and then i heard him
laughing to his friends like this fool
just started [ __ ] and pissing and then i
had the lighter and i closed i'm like
all right i'm gonna give you one more
chance bro and he's like i cut it off
and he started sprinting away and that
was it
he's like off into the night
he's like it's your own cousin
i don't know how much i like this guy
and then i also heard like
well maybe he was chewing something to
my mom like maybe he was gonna hurt her
that's what happened and i just
justified i mean he lives in my house i
got to feel safe somehow well i didn't i
didn't know about that yes you did or
your memory blocked it out on my memory
i remember
that because we're at [ __ ] friend's
house his dad's the cool guy his dad
we're at that house with a side door
right there [ __ ] okay okay but i
don't remember that that that situation
oh i was standing i remember what he did
to what's her name's husband who's now
oh yeah john told me
my uh stepdad blank
couldn't find a job he's a [ __ ] felon
and
his best friend's mom had a boyfriend no
no no
no no i'm talking about something else
what the [ __ ] happened who's who's
playing when okay remember
my friend that
the
i don't want to say her name you say it
can you bleep out the names yeah sure
are you going to yeah yeah he's going
gonna have to okay
husband oh you're talking about [ __ ]
yeah yeah
what he what he did he did what he did
because
he was beating up on
so we went and picked her up but he
didn't see blank in the car once again
he just saw me and her in the car so he
came
out of the house like a psychopath like
he was going to do something
and he was screaming another same
situation with the dumbass
and then blank got out of the car and
all you hear was like oh he was him
begging it was pretty [ __ ] pathetic
and then they walked around the house
somewhere and he didn't come back out
but link did and we got in the car and
left damn
how bad i don't know you never [ __ ]
asked never asked
[Laughter]
after we moved back from la after she
got she separated that guy and cracked
my head open
we stayed at their house yeah
i'll teach him how to be man that's what
he said
could you read him
you were yelling at me don't talk to him
you don't know how to be a man remember
he recorded it and he played it like for
an hour straight
him and his wife would [ __ ] [ __ ] and
bicker back and forth and one time he
was sitting there high as [ __ ] because
he smoked a lot of weed
and he recorded her bitching at him and
he like narrowed it down to don't talk
to him because he was he was trying to
talk to thomas and she was like don't
talk to him you're not a man don't talk
to him you're not a man and he recorded
it and he played that little bit over
and i don't remember that and over for
like an hour straight
i was a loser stop yes
i was living at the basement we had to
leave because he was trying to run we
were in like the it was like a car park
it was a garage we're staying there it
was a garage converted into another
house another room
and him and her got in a fight
and he was going to run the car through
that garage and i was like yeah done we
left i was like i can't have you doing
this [ __ ] i don't know how long we were
there but i remember staying there going
i like my mom's friends it was like two
weeks later her boyfriend their husband
is a [ __ ] loser and i was like six
yeah and i remember she was yelling at
me about something i was like [ __ ]
and i remember him i'll teach him how to
be man and i remember saying it's my
hand like it's crazy arizona yeah like
this guy's a [ __ ] loser
i was a child i remember thinking
he reminded me of nicholas cage and
raising arizona that's exactly what this
guy looks like
same hair the same
look on his tall skinny he was
what's his name in that movie
uh
let's not get on to that because i'm
gonna [ __ ] lose my mind trying it's a
good name too yeah it's a cool name hide
hide hide
yeah
he was hide um but i remember we were
standing in the yard and the neighbors
had cats oh
and i'm standing there just playing with
my soccer ball and there's like a little
kitten
and this fool's like
walks up and just boots it
it was over the power line
and i saw it flipping
yeah because i thought it died because
you know i didn't know cats fleeing and
they could land i was a child i go oh
i'm like you skipped the [ __ ] gap
yeah
you know i hate cats
yeah and i just remember thinking this
place sucks i didn't know he beat his
ass but back to blank i don't i don't
know what he did
he did something he did something
because he left her alone for a while
yeah of course he did he left her alone
of course he did but blake the only time
john my uncle john he is a witness
because i know blank
will [ __ ] you up like bruce lee
i've heard he's told me his story maybe
not now because he's all mad now yeah
he's told me his stories
and john was there for one of them and i
asked him to describe it he goes
everything we've ever heard is true
what so basically
blake could not get a job because he's a
[ __ ] felon and it was christmas time
this full felt like an [ __ ] my mom's
working he can't get a [ __ ] job and
he's a genius guys all these degrees
can't work he just wants to work at the
[ __ ] college he applied every college
everywhere just couldn't get a job
but he could teach his ass off
like he could tell and break [ __ ] down
for me i'm like
that's how it works
all right and he would just make [ __ ]
like solder and stuff together tweaker
[ __ ] but like he was a tweaker then he
was just had that brain
and he worked construction for
his best friend's mom's new boyfriend
got a construction job
he worked for like
three weeks straight all december he's
like [ __ ] it do i work whenever
and it came time to pay him and the guy
just stopped answering the call and he
knows that's his new girlfriend
her son's best friend
he knows his he knows who he is
he knows about this man he had to have
asked hey you know the guy i hired is he
cool yes but don't do nothing stupid to
him like they had to have had the
conversation that guy too you're talking
about yeah he was an ex-con too he just
thought he was hot yeah he did he really
thought he was hot [ __ ] he was older
dude he was like 15 years older yeah he
was like in his 40 45 and uh blake was
like 30 30 yeah we were so
in his prime
and john went with him
john and my stepdad were friends
he went with him
and he came back with his money that's
all i know because
blake got on the phones like and he
finally answered he's like yo
i just want to get that paycheck
christmas i want to get the shopping
done and then the guy must have been
[ __ ] up or something but he said
[ __ ] you and your family and your
christmas
and then i remember he put the phone
down
and he said it out like he's like he
just told me and he just like
put his shoes on funny though because he
already had beaten his ass already
because i didn't know any of this stuff
yeah i'm a kid i just think my stepdad's
working uh-huh and i remember he put the
phone down like shocked you just like
put his shoes on
it's like what's that look the [ __ ] was
that he went well i tried that's the
look he gave like
he's dead that's that's like
shrug it off
and he's like come on
john went with him i remember john was
like skinny at the time
like still a young kid going with the
older son-in-law or a brother-in-law his
new brother-in-law he's probably hearing
all these crazy stories like i'm not
going to jail [ __ ] but this guy's cool
we smoke weed together yeah like it was
like yeah i'll go back you up yeah yeah
so john went with him and just came back
and i go what happened
so john tells me this is john's
perspective he's like i get out of the
car guys in the driveway going what the
[ __ ] you gonna do about basically like
talking [ __ ] to my stepdad and he said
my stepdad got out of the car
walked over to him
and just did one of like a dip overhand
popped him in the mouth the full laid
back
[ __ ] collapsed got up
trying to fight and then he said my
stepdad was like oh [ __ ] he's up
and then john said thomas
we've watched movies
you've seen fights this is exactly what
happened he's like you know when john
klein van damme jumps up
spins and then releases that kick
he's on thomas
he jumped up
shoulder length in front of this man
whipped around in the air and roundhouse
kicked him asleep
one kick
guy collapsed onto the [ __ ] ground
bloody
and he said he stood over there went
through his [ __ ] pockets when his
truck got the money he's like all right
boom he's like that's how much i was
supposed to be paid and then somebody
had called the cops
and the mom knew better was like
blank did it did nothing he fell
oh she's like this is my new boyfriend
but this is like my son yeah oh yeah she
would have she had his back she would
have never she was like you know he's
gonna [ __ ] you up damn it my new
boyfriend doesn't know better yet that's
what she was going all of us hated him
anyway so it was like kick his ass he
was a whatever dude like i just knew him
i was like i don't know he was a pawn of
him
he wasn't like the friendly older man
that i expected yeah but i just remember
john was like
i mean the cop showed up
and everyone was like yeah that guy fell
because everybody knows my stepdad knows
better to go
yes say it say it and send him back to
jail do you know what the [ __ ] he's
involved with you don't say [ __ ] that's
pretty much what the mom was like
first he's like my kid second i know
better to say that this [ __ ]
assaulted this man this felon mm-hmm
anyway that's all i knew and john told
me he's like no
he jumped up by john clown van damme and
knocked this man out of sleep with ux
spinning kill well the other i saw him
like walking up because i guess this guy
thought he was going to do something
he's talking [ __ ]
he showed up at
what's-his-face's girlfriend's house the
yeah okay
and
he was
showing up talking [ __ ]
and blank was like i'm gonna go outside
i'm like come on man you just got home
he just got home like maybe two weeks
before that
he's like no no i'll be right back and i
was like oh [ __ ] here we go so i walk
outside
and this guy is coming walking towards
blank and does this kind of [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] karate kid almost oh i heard
the story and i was like what is he
doing
and blank just walked up to him and just
kicked him straight in the face
straight in the face like he was kicking
in the door because he had squatted down
a little bit and did this kick he kicked
him right in the [ __ ] that was the end
you showed me that on the
boxing bag heavy bag all the time
front kick yeah he would do but it was
like
yeah breaking [ __ ] he kicked him like
kind of up in the air and he fell in the
gutter
and then what's his face's stupid
girlfriend called cops
and so then i was
blank had to catch me because i was like
immediately like why did you you don't
call why are you calling cops yeah
so the cops came and blank's sitting
there with his because i guess he hit
him too i walked back in the house i'm
like i'm not watching this
and i guess he [ __ ] up his hand real
bad and he's sitting there and you could
see his hands swelling up and the cops
like what's wrong with your hand he's
like nothing
and he went to ask the guy what happened
he goes oh i tripped over that root on
that tree right there i tripped and like
face planted the the curb
and the cop was like
are you sure someone didn't hit you he
was like nobody hit me i fell
so the cops leave and that's when what's
his face's dad shows up
right so the ex it's the boyfriend
that just got beat up that just got beat
up his girlfriend's ex-husband big ass
yeah you know
and he's walking up and the guy that got
kicked in the face was walked over to
him to talk to him and with his left
hand
punched him
in the face
i heard about this with his left hand
just walking because this guy was huge
and just cracked him
and the guy
up in the air again
fell back into the garden like this guy
lives in the gutter at this point
got up after a while and just left left
lives his life so this guy's conscious
getting his butt getting his ass whooped
and it's like why do you keep messing
with these people
i told you to leave without messing with
these damn people
[ __ ] somebody but he's like dj
[ __ ] again you're not going to get
over you can't get over on this they're
gonna do stuff to you what's wrong with
you there's people out there like that
just were just dumb as [ __ ]
so i didn't know about the second time
so i know about the first one yeah i
didn't know yeah
but yeah i never got to see any of that
but i did remember the i did tell you
about the encounter everybody's heard
that with my friend's dad and this
literally was
teeth clatterings like in the cartoons
and i was like oh everything is true
and then john [ __ ] reestablished that
in my brain like everything we've ever
heard bam
that was his thing you know i was in
jail this [ __ ] trying to take my
cigarettes out you know i went bam
bam he's a [ __ ] hater funny he was
wow he was funny too though this
motherfucker's crazy wow
john you always say yeah you know blank
told me stories like i buy him then i
picked up this train and i got through
this train
johnson my uncle was hilarious so he was
like they could play off his story when
he wasn't around obviously i just keep
going he's like and then he was like
then i chopped this cigarette in half
and i was like two cigarettes wow
well whammy buckle john's a fool anyway
sewed that up
you your brain did put that out of your
head because i saw you standing there
with his best friend i don't remember
that yeah yeah so anyway he tied him up
in the field because that's where merced
is and he's like so i just poured it on
him like he's sitting there crying [ __ ]
his pants and i just closed the ladder
i'm like all right man i'll let you go
this stupid lap
oh god
but he told me all i i can't talk about
on here maybe if he's dead if he's dead
i'll talk about it yeah but there's a
bunch of stuff when they broke up and
got divorced and he was like my dad's
always seeing him on the weekends and
[ __ ] still but he was at his bet the
girl the mom that let her boyfriend get
annihilated
her house we were at her house damn and
i was having like weekends out there
that's when i learned how to throw
knives you ever see me just randomly
guys on the podcast
if you ever see me just doing this
this balancing balancing [ __ ] okay it's
because of that what can we do that one
knife i remember that night the one
weekend i had it i remember it because
i'm always balanced like yeah i could
probably throw this right into the
[ __ ] wall through that oh right there
um
so
we'll move on about that
my last thing
you ready
i usually hit that whole vape no did you
drink that whole beer no cause then i'll
have to go to the bathroom again that's
my last question that's fine okay go
ahead
when did you become a compulsive liar
1971.
all right continue oh real quick really
funny my mom's one of her favorite
movies is fast times my partner in the
dopest his last name is hand oh no [ __ ]
his last name is hand and in the movie
mr hand is the is the teacher and on the
back of her car it says aloha mr hand
she has a sticker on her car and she
really likes the movie
my
business partner's last name's hand
his high school is where they filmed oh
no way
yeah damn so i just thought it was like
when i met him like it was just too
perfect there's no way this isn't gonna
work
out you're too awesome this all works
like
anyway moving on
ready
[Music]
start doing it every time og starts
telling the story [ __ ] liar
you ready
are you sure that you're ready
are you sure that you are ready
we'll see what happens okay i was just
waiting for you to say anything i know
you're ready all right here we go my
last point
my mom's favorite band is stained
or creed
i want you guys to think that's a fact
that is a lie you guys think that's a
fact that is a bold face life she was
cool until they said that
that's a lie are you ready yeah
my mom only likes sammy hagar
that is a
serious that's fighting words right
there
i mean you are going to fight watch
i'm going to go first
okay i'm ready
ready
my mom is moving down here to l.a very
soon
all right
is that a surprise to you
why do you look so surprised
we've had long extensive conversations
about this
go ahead
i'm saying it
and now react
this is you start speaking i'm speaking
i'm just kidding all right [ __ ]
you're gonna move down here come on
sure are you are you [ __ ] thinking
about it no
so you're not gonna move
i want to move
it's a start this is as hard as
interviewing og sometimes man no because
okay like we have our entire life in in
wherever we're at
so should i say where we're at
madeira california but i mean and then
like we need to plan first i need to
like a step by step we gotta we got me
and you are gonna have to like sit down
and like this is gonna happen this this
this this this mean like i do with every
[ __ ] thing in my life yeah but when
me and you talk you're usually staring
at your phone so i have no idea not a
true statement always when is he not on
his phone he's a professional
don't i didn't ask you what he was i
asked you when is he not on his phone
you know how many times i get on my
phone i'm around somebody goes so sorry
guys i'm just posting this thing and
checking this email one second give me a
second and i go
i'm done
okay and i always make it a factory
sorry i know my phone i get but i always
say it
anyway so we're we'll talk about this
but yes i would love to move down here i
love l.a
ew you're gross
get away from me
[Music]
that's the [ __ ] feather of 2022. i spit
on you and then
wait is that your final question no but
that's incredible
oh my god
the tart feather of 2022 uh
loogie
you're the candidate for this okay
remember that one time you're like
you're always on your phone you're
always on your phone face [ __ ] like
you're always on your phone
wow
the [ __ ] out of here she's fiddling
she's not the [ __ ] are you gonna believe
this
are they gonna oh they don't believe it
[ __ ] i'll stop seeing you stop all right
you ready you're gonna move down here
soon okay all right what do you do for
olivia i drive you nuts
no i i am a manicurist i am a nail tech
i do nails for a living
and you smoke
plastic objects what it worked
um so you do nails you do nails and
stuff currently your nails have pushed
trees all over yes and yes they're very
very cool
so maybe we'll pop up some really nice
pictures or something my mom is really
good at lying deflecting and nails
so
i'll i'll say that um my mom where we're
from
for all the girls out there for all the
four percent of girls out there or the
dudes that know about nails too
my mom charges less than a fifth of what
she should be charging because where
we're from nobody's got money like that
out here i know girls that do full sets
with art 350 300
70 isn't the most you probably charge uh
the most type of charge is like 125 oh
[ __ ] that's not that bad yeah it took me
three hours
that's different i'm talking about when
people come in and get the [ __ ] oh
yeah french tips are [ __ ] not even
french tips like the long ones with art
yeah those are like 65 70. see what i'm
saying they're growing what the [ __ ]
yeah because down here 250 450 is normal
when you're getting bomb as cool [ __ ]
and most of it's press on [ __ ] like
press on art what yeah most of it is
so
so my mom's gonna move down here my
little brother's moving down here
now we just need to get your sister down
here let's get my sister down here my
little brother's moving down here all
right i'm gonna my brother's gonna be
famous as [ __ ] for something super
[ __ ] fun and cool i already know that
he's moving down here they're moving
down here my mom we're going to start a
nail shop that's the goal we're going to
start a nail shop because my mom
complains every six seconds that's like
my [ __ ] hands hurt i love working
so we got to get her to stop doing that
and running it
and maybe you do like one client a week
and you're like yo i charge this
[ __ ] six hundred dollars no i'm
not gonna be all that why not i don't
know because i don't if you do something
ridiculous ridiculous it's worth the
money yeah of course there's but what i
consider what you consider like
ridiculous is like just letting me let
me do my thing that's what i'm saying
the the worst part of it is i mean
yeah bring pictures this is what i kind
of like but i don't want to copy that
picture yeah you know i'll let me just
change this or change that or you know
i'll put my like little
spin on it
but a lot of now especially with the
internet a lot of it is copying other
people's stuff and it's like i want to
do that you know yeah i get it but what
i'm just saying with any business yeah
if i'm gonna do him like oh we got to be
the best one but when i do
when i do do what i do it always comes
out better than the picture than than
the person brought me yeah yeah yeah for
sure uh well i'll send you some pictures
this [ __ ] looks like your shirt it's
like wow it's on a nail what the [ __ ]
all the pictures you ever seen rosie all
the crazy [ __ ] she used to post on her
nails when he used to live in merced and
she get her nails done all the time um
yeah that she did all that [ __ ]
so
that's what we're gonna do you're gonna
move down here and you can stop doing
that
and then do whatever else you're gonna
do in your life and just don't have to
work
yeah
i don't mind working though i like
working i know but you always say that
then you go my [ __ ] hands hurt yeah
this [ __ ] talk my ear off like
there's always that and eventually
you're gonna want to stop doing that
yeah eventually i won't be able to do it
anymore and then you might as well stop
before you're like this yeah
right yeah because we'll stop now
so that's the plan that's the goal
that's the last thing i want to talk
about
new
plan is for you guys to move down here
i thought it was just going to be my
brother but now it's like no once you
just all move down here
if you don't like it it's still there
you should go back yeah if you don't
like it but it's going to work 100 i'm
not going to do something of a business
is not going to be awesome right or make
a [ __ ] sick and you
have experienced for the last however
many [ __ ] years how are you doing
nails now um before your brother was
born so 18 18 years at least right
and you know all the [ __ ] that people
don't like all this [ __ ] that people do
like all the stuff that the trends that
are gonna die like no no don't do that
we're not gonna be doing that here like
if you had your own shop and called the
shots you'd have the best shop yeah so
there it is and all you do is like oh
we'll just pay for it but when you do it
when you um
hire like other techs they bring their
style into it too so that's different
when you do that you have okay well you
like that kind of art you want to go to
that person oh you want this you go to
that but you know yeah but our [ __ ]
would be like this warehouse oh this
section is this that's that section
that's that section
if we're gonna do a business it's gonna
be [ __ ] tight yeah about when we do
the business because we are gonna do it
so
very soon and somebody said why don't
you just make like a smoking lounge like
oh you [ __ ] we could legally
make a smokey leg yeah well because you
don't sell the wheat not only that i
won't allow kids in there
[ __ ] no no because kids destroy
everything nope no kids sorry if you
can't leave your kid at home you can't
have your nails done today
that's it so
that's one thing about the nail shafts
that sucks like oh
the [ __ ] is getting her [ __ ] nails
done and you're not paying attention
up the whole salon oh
yeah it's like how did you why did you
bring your kids you can't control
the kid knows that you can't do nothing
your hands are like this you know so
they act crazy yeah yeah i
spend a lot of time in the salon so they
[ __ ] suck and nobody watches their
child and there's a few when you're like
yeah i [ __ ] with this lady yeah yeah i
have a few clients that their kids are
cool they will just sit there and like
yeah i'm saying when they check their
kid like thank you at least you [ __ ]
know
one thing about my dad
i have to check my little brothers and
sisters like yo dad check these
[ __ ]
it's not like my dad ever that's me but
i'm like yo you have to so you gotta be
able to check him with justice you gotta
do sometimes [ __ ] damn yeah
but my thing to all my brothers and
sisters growing up that's why they
didn't none of my brothers just like me
until they're about eight
oh because you're always on their ass
well then i do this a lot
if they're being [ __ ] i'll go like this
touch their head go
go get away from me
i'm not gonna hit you i'm your brother i
can't hit you cause i'm way older than
you also don't talk [ __ ] to me or i'm
just gonna push you like this and you
wanna do i'm gonna grab a pillow i'm
gonna you can't come near me oh you're
watching tv i'm just gonna hold it in
front of your head you can't watch it
and they just
ah they leave the room because they
can't do anything i will annoy them to
death
but they're i didn't do nothing wrong
i'm trying to chill with you don't be a
[ __ ] to me i get it
yeah it's like i can't do nothing to you
so i'm gonna do everything around
touching you
besides pushing your face
i love doing that [ __ ] but they're all
grown they're all getting bigger my
littlest brother's eight now
he's like a [ __ ]
teenager he's super mature so there's no
more
i'm [ __ ] so excited
i can't wait i'm so tired of going to
motherfucker's sixth grade graduations
i am over it
i love it i love like oh come do this
but
i live so far
well so what are you gonna do with your
brother's graduation
rocco's yeah
drive down
it's a high school
graduation we zoom in
it's no i'm saying for the important
things that always come i never not show
up i'm just saying i'm tired of
doing you do show up
like yo you drove you got 12 hours yeah
all right but i have to film tomorrow i
have to go
it's like [ __ ] dude i wish i didn't have
to because i could chill and not be
stressed out
but i can't make everything like i go to
the quinceaneras i go to the big things
now i can't do it anymore i used to go
to everything but i can't dude it's too
much
it costs too much money to be gone for
four or five days out of a week
you know
hey you what's up hit this pen no we're
almost done no get high a little you
can't make it all the way through
without smoking with you peer pressure
peer pressure your parents yeah you're
just going to make a problem
no hit it for like oh you have to hit it
like three seconds at least
that's the [ __ ] bill clinton inhale
it's fine you're gonna be the next
president
all right so this has been chris tiger
from fifth element thank you guys so
much for being here
um
okay
anything else you want to add do you
want to just keep making this noise for
everyone driving thinking their car is
rattling yes
i don't hear it in case you do it soft
oh i can't hide your hair of course
harry it's earth it makes sounds
anything you want to add
bob barker
yeah we're gonna go see wayne or what
yeah
do you want to go watch everything
everywhere all at once yeah yes
i want to watch it again
oh it's so high yeah i'll go watch it
again yes we're gonna go see we is it in
colorado i think so but i think it
passed we're going to call it no it
didn't pass it in may something
it's me weirdo
it's in may
yeah i think it's in we'll figure it out
we got it it's not there's also
tenacious d's coming tenacious d is
coming too it's gonna be sick
pearl jams this week i think in fresno
stained i don't know who that is
her favorite band um who else is coming
oh people choose b-52s or planes snow's
play i don't know who snow is who's that
not me dammit
it's the guy that's sitting singing
former
oh the regular he was deported
jim carrey i thought he got deported
back i don't
that was a joke oh
all right oh how do you feel about
madonna oh she's looking crazy lately my
mom loves madonna ever since i was
growing up how do you feel right now i
don't know she's looking pretty she
looks pretty weird yeah why is she doing
that because she's getting old let it go
she's not going to yeah i could say but
just like she still acts the same but
she just looks like she's some kind of
like roger the alien now she started to
look scared she's scary yeah she's so
awesome she needs to knock it off and
just let it age
make mickey rourke would look so cool if
he didn't do that to himself yeah but
that's because he was a boxer for a long
time i understand he's still awesome i
understand i got informers stuck so hard
every time i was trying to talk i was
trying to like
[ __ ] anything else you want to add keep
your pet spayed and neutered uh yeah but
i don't remember right now
or something it was good that was good
there was something that i was going to
say but i don't remember now
we'll see if you remember in a second
thank you guys we uh we don't got all
our cameras going we're in [ __ ]
shambles right now but it's all right
i'm glad we got y'all died
no we got you guys going okay uh but
yeah thank you guys this was fun
all right so we're trying to go to
frankenstein's later yeah
toy store
we're trying to go watch this movie
we need to eat food because i'm [ __ ]
hungry these vans have too many checkers
i want to get some different ones stop
it
i had too many checkers
that was a good one that was a good
that was a good one
remember you got one
i like it
all right
right now what's your favorite drug ever
mushrooms
i said drug mushrooms not a drug um
every hard drug any hard drug if it
wasn't deathly what was the funnest
thing you ever did
all right cool that's what i want to
hear why ah
it was it
took you
to another dimension
yeah okay no no no no no
that's exactly the part i was on
okay
anything else you want to add you've
been uh
guessed on here for two times two times
now
you must know somebody
you must know somebody here how do you
feel
i'm okay
we didn't get high this time no which is
okay
i put tinctures in your beer when you're
in the bathroom this one right here yes
i didn't drink it
i didn't put pictures in here well i
didn't drink it anyways i'm lying i did
not i shouldn't you should have it
i should have did it why has that been
funny
i asked you if i could take mushrooms
you said no
this [ __ ] doesn't want to smoke a
joint but i'll tell you she wants to
take mushrooms as you go
yeah and all her stories change to the
truth
and we finally get it all out we'll give
you the mushrooms then
next time i could have brought my own no
no the mushrooms are too much for you if
i can micro dose one that's not going to
do enough smoke hit this again relief
hit this one more time hard five seconds
hard though one two hard i can hear it
you're not hitting it i can hear this
mic
[Music]
yes
yes did you really do that that was
amazing where did you get that she's old
enough to know what the [ __ ] i know what
that was that was my last new sound
effect for the day what else do you got
on there a bunch
drama what do you want
i got some new ones okay
i played all the other ones
that one was that one was definitely
pretty good right that one was movie
quality that's hands that's the kickoff
story time oh you guys [ __ ] ready
for everyone driving i'm sorry oh they
saw the semi went by
my bad also if you're driving on spotify
and watching you're an [ __ ] don't
watch just listen
if you're driving but if you're not an
[ __ ] watch that [ __ ] when you're not
driving thanks
all right mom
oh do i have a question what
when you do if you do ever get tyson on
here
my mom wants to be here when mike
tyson's here yeah i have to no i'm gonna
you know i'ma do i'm gonna sit right
there and not say a word take a picture
and send it to everybody where were you
like where were you no that's not fair
you can't do that
you can't do that no
but i'm gonna clip it from jack and jill
where where are you
the [ __ ] bird that's what i want to
say
i can't let you be why because you're
[ __ ] insane i'm just gonna sit over
there and not say a word
i promise
i don't believe you at all hi
don't believe her yeah you should you
should believe me because i would not
say a word
don't believe her at all
we'll see we're working on it we'll see
um how about this
i make up a list of like 10 things and
you give me the [ __ ] truth
without any [ __ ] or any but you know
they did that
and then you can come
you give me 10.
that's so solid
so much that's too many that's that
question i still have she holds things
back yeah because i know that you are
and it drives me insane when you say no
i'm not i'm not spitting in my [ __ ]
hand right now that's what she's doing
to me i don't have shoes on that she's
lacing your shoes like i'm not dumb
[Music]
don't do that
you're going to get 20 22 tired
feathered
that's funny
first of all i'm not gonna do anything
that's gonna be inappropriate around
mike tyson
okay
so you should really let me be there
that's how you hit it how about this
you keep your room really clean
and if when i come home
everything you're supposed to do is done
you can come see mike tyson why can't
you just let me see mike tyson if you
are here before the [ __ ] lights
outside come on
you can come and watch my days
what other things have you said to me
if you can take this punch
and stay awake
i'm done
see
i'm done um okay we'll end it with that
we'll end with that thank you for being
here mike tyson okay we'll see
and we're not saying that we booked him
yet for everyone out there like whoa
where can i get his edibles i want his
edibles probably at a [ __ ]
store where
no but where do you know which one see
you know at the top of my head asked if
i had any questions
i how about this one i don't know thank
you i have no idea and just say i know
with within 10 seconds on this computer
i can find it
i don't know if i would eat them though
i think i would just have them
because they're so iconic that's so good
collectors on them i know everyone out
there doesn't know it's evander
holyfield bit ears
oh it's so great they're called mike
bites that's amazing they're called my
smartest thing they're the best smartest
[ __ ] ever
um these are my favorite episodes
besides oh geez because i get to just
talk [ __ ] and i know the answer to most
of these things i just want to hear you
say and it makes me
see that
that's me with myself inside me with my
inner child which one bro
both of them are me
and i'm the taller one i guess
and i'm like don't worry bro
right there is me i guess
that's a bong no it's not i'm kidding
mom it's a face i know i'm kidding
all right i think we did our job that we
were supposed to do here and we spoke
about stuff i have spoken and you you
held back a little bit you did way
better yeah but there's some stuff that
i don't want to say held back yeah
we got season three no we don't marty we
do have season three
so what i'm gonna i'll come back next
year that's what i'm saying
that's fine yeah
yeah that's fine
uh what's the date
today's date seventh your birthday's
next week yeah yeah
next week 51 punches right in the chest
it's gonna be so sick
um
okay that's everything thank you
you're welcome
thank you thank you thank you mark it's
wonderful thank you
let's really hope that this footage is
perfect i'm going to say it is no it's
going to be
[ __ ] the best it's going to be the
best one ever there's going to be a
bunch of bleach before the names oh the
names
remember i said it three times more than
that so in there
we gotta bleep these names and if it's
too pronounced
oh yeah blur this yeah
yeah blur it with a cut out of her face
i have pictures you could use okay and
i'm like and so i went
put your face
over your face
don't do that you're the roseanne barr
of real life
all right
you could take that one it's not a bad
one why am i rosham hard because she's a
little wild and scary and loud but she's
reasonable when toward the end of like
the show
she became reasonable when her kids got
out yeah wrapped up with a message
yeah you haven't seen the show lately
have you
no i'm talking about the [ __ ] show
yeah the show's still on i want to talk
about the connors oh it's about roseanne
well she was on the first what i think
season then she said all that dumb [ __ ]
and got kicked off her own show hold on
it's like what the hell best response
ever what i thought the [ __ ] was white
that's what she said
about saying that [ __ ] about the
politician i thought the [ __ ] was white
it's the funniest response ever because
that's the tr
that's from her heart and she went
oh i [ __ ] up
i thought that [ __ ] was white
okay she said that on her phone in her
house going [ __ ]
so i'm like that was a real response
because that's what i would have said if
i said some stupid [ __ ] like she said
she said some stupid [ __ ] stupid
ignorant [ __ ] ignorant ignorant
but she thought she was like
got her like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] what oh [ __ ] i'm cancelled i
cancelled [ __ ]
she should've just rolled with him like
[ __ ] i [ __ ] up they killed her off of
the connor they she died on the show
they murdered her well she had like a
health problem and died on the show yes
that's how they got rid of her
yeah i didn't watch it oh my god you're
just [ __ ] giving her hash pens like
i'm getting rid of my roseanne
just again like drop dead friend mud
pies
i just love i hope have you seen him
drop dead fred no oh it's so good what
do you have to watch drop dead fred you
haven't seen [ __ ] fast times you get
some good [ __ ]
you can watch drop dead fred with your
whole family yeah okay
fast times well i watch it now that you
tell me about so
he does call her mega [ __ ] a lot
yeah
it's okay but doing it like the pigeons
yeah yeah it's funny it's it's really
it's kidsy
it's about imaginary friends it's great
okay and that man never in another good
movie
which man they dropped in frederick yes
he was who is he oh my god i've never
seen him in anything else he's more um
british comedy oh okay that makes sense
yeah he was i can't remember his name
rick something i can't remember his last
name right now miranda's no
no no just the kids no but he died
recently like maybe five years ago i
stopped talking [ __ ] about my friend
rick rick moranis
no the rick from drop dead fred i love
that guy that guy's hilarious
i know
i wrote that movie
he's been around the third grade i'm
like all right man let's get out of here
everything so if you ever hear me say i
wrote that song i'm lying yeah in case
you hear me like at an event or a
restaurant i wrote that he did this all
night last night every song that came on
he wrote that song when he was in third
grade he wrote that song when he was in
sixth grade he was for the talent show i
didn't know they were gonna take it he
wrote the song when he was still never
got any royalties youtube i said it too
never got no royalties for this orange
juice jones actually making a true
statement we're like now you're full of
[ __ ] and then he gets mad it's tough
because he lies so much it's not a lie
it's just entertaining myself what are
you doing now i'm singing
in my head or shoes jones standing in
the rain i thought you were the singing
informer i'm not anymore i don't know
why she's close to my head no it's doing
it or just jones is stronger no sing
sing porn on blondes no i'm kidding do
it
um
let's end this for everyone out there
that's like yo what's happening
what happened my mom's drinking warm
beer
marty's just laughing
i am starving
and i think it's pretty much it hi marty
thank you for being here hey thanks for
being here you're welcome
happy mother's day everybody yeah happy
mother's day for tomorrow yes what did
you get me
uh i got you not enough some checkered
vans
not big enough
i'll get you
solid some hash pens maybe hash print no
i want costco pizza vegan version do
they have that just as good no they
don't have that
come on man if they had that everything
[ __ ] crushing it right now
okay chicken make
[ __ ] costco all right let's get out
of here i'm [ __ ] starving thank you
guys so much for being here i'm uh
you're just talking um this has been the
dopamine podcast be sure to leave a
[ __ ] like on this video
um also follow us on instagram dope as
usual podcast on instagram uh click the
link in there there's twitter there's
everything we got thank you for being
here if you're on spotify thank you for
being here marty thank you so much for
being here mom thank you for lying your
ass off it was such a good episode
it was such a good episode she remembers
all right thank you so much for being
here guys have a best day
you can't lie such a dog camera you i'm
not even you're the one that's just
he just makes it the seventh oh yeah
you're lying i forgot
it's every seventh of the month she lies
[Music]